all right
scum and villainy please welcome
kevin smith and mark bernardin
[Applause]
welcome back everybody to the matinee
if you will the saturday afternoon
matinee of
fat man beyond kids
[Applause]
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard
there's a there's a weird little sit
down there it was well it's the
afternoon man it's a chill out period
this is afternoon delight it's like that
song about relatives [ __ ] hey
um look at this this is the first one of
these that
that i'll be signing a uh skelega it's
the masters universe figure showing up
very very cool
how's everybody doing today kids
[Applause]
we were just in the newly paved back
alley
the green roof valley in all of
hollywood you can eat off that [ __ ]
floor
and people do yeah some guests
a funny but sobering thought uh but now
we're ready to go kids uh
uh i think uh we've got a show i think
we do
uh before we dive into it of course uh
we're
lucky anytime somebody wants to throw a
dime behind this uh
train wreck of a podcast and so today we
have another proud sponsor ladies and
gentlemen
it's our first live read yes
and our first live sponsor so hopefully
you give them a lot of love even if
you're like well i have no use for this
product whatsoever
perhaps you just support it in theory
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
tonight's sponsor
[Music]
everybody
now for those of you who are like what's
blue chew
tell them what they're just applauded
mark well here's the thing
uh i think the the ad copy is all about
pitching tents
yes i believe yeah they wrote jokes for
us so here we go
it's summer camping season let's talk
about pitching tents
that's right this episode is sponsored
by blue chew
guys good that's good copy actually yeah
not bad right yeah yeah
uh it's about getting your dick hard
it's absolutely what blue chew does man
you chew it you swallow it and [ __ ]
party time shortly thereafter how long
does it take to kick in
uh they don't specify because i'm
imagining there's some biological [ __ ]
going on depending on what's in your
body and your dick
and how that interfaces with the yeah
blue cheese it's like do you consume the
whole thing like what if some [ __ ] gets
stuck in your teeth
will you then be like half masked or
something like that oh your teeth get
hard oh oh
[ __ ] i'm going back to my dentist i'm
like [ __ ] you i got blue chew
uh blue cheese and a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets
at a fraction of the cost you can take
them anytime day or night so you can
plan ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity
arises the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll get your
prescription within days
no visits to doctor's offices no awkward
conversations about how your dick
doesn't get hard
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
while they know your dick isn't getting
hard
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared show what you assume like
when you're at the pharmacy like look at
all these
[ __ ] soft pieces of [ __ ] they're all
here for [ __ ] dick pills aren't they
yes this is johnson clearly you're here
for dick bills too
uh so yeah so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform
blue chew can help and we've got a
special deal for fat man followers
try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code fat man at checkout just pay
five dollars of shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code fatman to
get your first month
free visit bluechew.com for more details
folks and
important safety information of course
nobody wants you eating too many blue
chews
uh and we thank the good folks at blue
chew the mighty folks at blue chew the
dick
hardening folks at blue chew for
bringing us together this afternoon
blueju.com give it up for them ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
we salute you luchu blue chew um all
right man
well how have you been what have you
been doing for the last few days
since we did this last few days ago uh
i'm doing good
man i'm doing good been keeping busy
taking meetings writing [ __ ]
what are you looking for oh here it is i
was looking for my drinks
i'm listening believe me i'm just all
right no you look trying to hydrate as
well oh
good for you so what have you been doing
um
nothing i was really hoping you would
cover me for the opening of the can and
[ __ ] like that
nope um i uh me and mark did something
yesterday we did a thing
we did i was on twitter
[Laughter]
we just got real stoned ate a bunch of
blue chew and saw what happened man
yeah oh what do we do with these go to
my new tick tock account
aka dick tuck
me and mark got together at my house we
didn't need bluetooth to do that we like
each other
and uh and we recorded a commentary
track for
mark's episode of uh masters of the
universe revelation
we did
[Applause]
um it was a good time we did uh
basically we're doing a little series
called the
masters of the universe revelation
celebration where we just celebrate
uh the writers on the show we take each
episode we do the commentary track with
the writer that wrote the episode so
mark did
three episode three so we sat down
yesterday and recorded that tim sheridan
who did
four came over and then next week dia
who did episode two and eric who did
episode five
uh will come over and i sat solo for my
episode one but the rest of the time it
was like me sitting there and
chit chatting and whatnot it was like
this but you weren't here
yeah and i was on the other side and it
was weird because i'm never on that side
and we were sharing like a little cat
bird seat it was like we're in a rumble
seat it was exciting it was a
side-by-side
chair so we went parking it looked like
the love toilet
is what we were sitting on together um
so you'll be able to see that when the
episodes drop because they're full of
spoilers and stuff
the commentary track um but that we just
saw each other the other day so normally
when we do this we're like what you've
been up to
and now it's like what you've been up to
for the last oh 12 hours
um well i watched a i watched a trailer
for a thing that got me very excited
what is it the new blue chew excited
yes it got me like i don't need a pill
excited uh the new shang chi
trailer yeah that's right that dropped
did i see a dragon in that trailer an
underwater dragon
a fing fam fumi dragon do you think
that's who the [ __ ] that i think that's
who the [ __ ] that is
i've it's so [ __ ] up i've been waiting
years for fing fang foom and i saw the
image and it never crossed my mind
you know it's almost like move away
where's ping pang boom
is that who that is i think that's i
mean they haven't confirmed anything but
they're not gonna but i think that's who
that is they didn't confirm that it's
uh the abomination either but it looks
like he was in the trailer as well
looked like he was fighting wong as well
yeah
yeah what's that all about i don't know
but it's like the best mortal kombat we
didn't get when we got mortal kombat
i like the idea that they're like you
remember all the people these
[ __ ] beating movies
they come back and fight in pits
um it looks uh phenomenal um and uh the
ten rings we actually get to see
in action uh growing up the ten rings
were literally
the ten rings it was just bling but now
there's but now it's weapons and weapons
the armbands that kind of come out i was
in a target and i saw a [ __ ] ton
of shang chi toys really did you buy
some i did not
but i didn't buy any toys as a matter of
fact way to [ __ ] like put me on the
spot
what happened to you yeah i bought every
katie figure they had
um but i you know i was looking at the
dragon it did not say fing fang boom on
it that's why
that's why when i saw the trailer i
didn't fing it at all i was like
did it just say like fill the dragon but
it would be amazing like [ __ ] why
wouldn't they this would be the time to
do bing fang boom you got it that's
right i remember when i
saw the first uh trailer for the
avengers and you know those [ __ ]
things that were flying in the sky
they had the one shot of it coming
around the side of the building i was
like holy [ __ ] it's
thing fang [ __ ] fool which was like
that year's version of like it's got to
be mephisto
that one's a mephisto no that one's
mevisto um
i'd be i'd be happy to see some [ __ ]
fig fang foo fingers crossed yeah what'd
you think of the trailer in general
um i dug it because we're getting now a
little bit more context for what the
movie is
and what shang chi's relationship to his
parents are like we didn't know in the
first one that michelle yo was playing
his mom which is the [ __ ] badass
person in the world yeah and the idea
that the duality of his father is
clearly like the worst bad guy ever
the mandarin i guess and then his his
mother is
like this being a pure wonder in light
who's trying to keep him on the
on the right side of the of the force
and uh and that that's his conflict is
who am i going to be
and do i have to follow the footsteps of
my parents or is there a third way
that's
that's purely mine it's it sounds like
marvel's version of
at close range remember that movie jesus
how's it going to go star wars but sure
at close range
yeah i guess you're right it
does sound a bit more like that than an
obscure 80s movie that people don't
remember
but it had that great tagline you see
the jagged edge it's just like that
remember the tagline was like like
father like son
like hell wow they could totally rock
that on the [ __ ] you know hey kevin
feige use that for [ __ ] free
from one kevin to you we see you
uh no i dug it i dug it i'm here for it
yeah for sure
um i'm the i'm totally there for it i'm
probably there for it far more than i am
the eternals although i'm there for the
eternals as well but this trailer has me
excited whereas the eternals trailer
has been going like what happens wait
what's the connection move aside is that
captain america like i'm looking for
the marvel connection here the marvel
connections a little easier to find
yeah i mean i'm betting the second
internals trailer will have more
context to it like what is this about
story trailer yeah
not just it's pretty yeah it looks epic
what are they doing they're epic yeah
um titans trapped on earth i don't know
if you heard this
i know tell me more that's that's what i
read today
they're like they're titans trapped on
earth and i was like right on
what does that mean yeah still isn't
[ __ ] it's i still need bluetooth come
on
um uh yeah i did watch that trailer uh
what have i been watching too yesterday
was friday so
apple tv dropped physical physically
watching the rose burn show
no i haven't been it's [ __ ] good yeah
yeah it has nothing to do with any of
this [ __ ] and whatnot but uh
but she you know she's been in this kind
of [ __ ] like she was an x-men so it
counts
um it's good it's totally worth watching
is it do they just play the olivia
john song over and over again they
haven't done it yet really well you know
like wait till episode [ __ ]
10 and be like let's get faster
that's the title that's the round
they're keeping in the chamber
that's what i would do in 1980 if you
knew john song i'm like oh wait till
they get there
yes we're going to surprise him with
this um
that's i watch that i've really been
doing them i've been doing a lot of
writing this week
been writing with the kid the kid and i
are writing this script and we finished
it we finished the script together yeah
which was nice
pretty and pretty weird experience um
writing with somebody who came from my
balls at one point and [ __ ]
like periodically i was looking at [ __ ]
she wrote and i was like this [ __ ]
wouldn't exist
unless like i found your mother [ __ ]
hot you know like
that's how it all we got there it's how
i got a co-writer man i
[ __ ] her into existence a long time
ago
and lord knows she did the opposite with
the script she really unfucked it man
like she's
she got you know i think i talked about
it last week no
i didn't so [ __ ] heartbreaking it was
a moment you know and then i was like ah
we learn from these moments and grow you
know i had this [ __ ] career i stand
before you as somebody who's been here
since the [ __ ] mid-90s
um where in the beginning of my career
and for a long long time as a matter of
fact people be like oh
he writes the most natural dialogue he
writes the way
[ __ ] we sound man like we're 20
somethings
he's [ __ ] sounds like us and you know
i i built a [ __ ] career legitimately
off of that
so here i am writing a script with my
20-something kid and i hand her some
[ __ ] i write
with dialogue for 20-somethings and she
goes dad
bro no 20-something sounds like this
she's going they all sound like
50-year-olds
and i was like you're out of your
[ __ ] mind i said i am known for my
20-something dialogue she was like in
your 20s bro
and i really had to like face the facts
that like
i don't write for young people anymore
my character's age up
with me generally speaking masters the
universe was great because it was fake
shakespeare's fake spear
so you don't have to write you know
[ __ ] dialogue that sounds like oh
this is what a [ __ ] giant talking
tire
would say in the real world yeah so here
though you have to actually worry about
how people sound and stuff
and she gave me she was like let me
write it and i was like okay
and she wrote it when she flipped it
back to me i was like
this is what 20 something sound like i
would never want to hang out with the
[ __ ] 20s
like they don't there's no clever
conversation it's just like move [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] and i'm like this [ __ ] counts
holy [ __ ] did you have that like the sad
like george michael
bluth walk around the block
[Music]
he's dragging your laptop behind you
thank god it's a multi-generational tell
because then at least i could write
these down some old people
yeah for the old people and [ __ ] she
goes that makes sense you do that i'm
like [ __ ] thanks
uh but it's been great man and like
we're kind of ahead of the game we
weren't supposed to start writing a
script
until um well it's like two-step process
right there's a place that has a thing
we can't say what it is yet they haven't
announced it
but there's a place that owns a thing
not unlike what we went through with
mattel
and masters universe that's a place that
owns a thing and they're like we want
you to work on our thing
if we like your story so we were at a
different company and they're like we
got a thing and we want you to work on
this thing if we like your story and
they liked our stories they're like
[ __ ]
go work on this thing so the next step
is to go sell it
to somebody else so we go pitch it uh
this week
um and uh you know generally you
wouldn't write the script until
somebody put down money and [ __ ] and
said all right we're doing this as a
show but like you know
we were sitting there right in the
outline i was like let's just [ __ ] go
for it
like just all we have to do is write
dialogue that's all an outline is is
[ __ ]
there's a script without dialogue so
let's throw in some [ __ ] [ __ ] to say
i know how 20 some things talk so like
record scratch so we uh we did we kind
of jumped the gun a little bit um
and wrote the script and had like a
[ __ ] blast doing it now we're going
backwards and writing the outline but we
know the
the story of the whole series and stuff
so it's going to be simple and so we had
to do a second pitch
on thursday for like the big big bosses
at the company because they were like we
heard about this thing we want to hear
about this
and so we pitched to them as well and
they were like um okay
notes on your pitch number one remember
when you were bickering with each other
it's adorable like make sure you do that
in real life i was like what fight we
always do
like but uh it was good man and it's
weird like going into that world
with the kid because you know it's a
when you get to pitch things
it's it it's all the potential right
it's like oh my god it could be a
[ __ ] thing it could be a show
or it could be absolutely [ __ ]
nothing and i've been around for a
quarter century or more at this point so
i certainly know how to
fail you know i made yoga hosers i
really know how to [ __ ] fail
so i know what it's like when you're
like oh this would be amazing we spent
so much time talking about this thing
and building the story and [ __ ] like
that
and then for it to just hit a wall and
[ __ ] slide down like
slow [ __ ] and then just die on the floor
so
it feels irresponsible bringing someone
you love
into that world you know what i'm saying
we're just like every step of the way so
far with this
has seemed very easy she's like you're
kidding we could just do this i was like
yeah man we had a cool story they liked
it let's just go do it and stuff
but there could come a point where
they're like oh this thing ain't gonna
happen like i worked on kingdom keepers
for a year and all of a sudden they were
like that's not gonna happen and it just
like [ __ ] went away
could happen here as well and then i'll
be [ __ ] responsible for like
breaking her heart like you told me
there was hope in this world and [ __ ]
but at the same time you know that's the
possibility it's like you don't
not do the thing because you're scared
it might not work out you do the thing
because what if it [ __ ] works out
so we're in the period right now where
it's like oh my god what if this
works out what if we were doing this a
[ __ ] year from now and we're doing
the
shooting this [ __ ] thing so it's it's
been
exciting man and kind of fun like seeing
it through
through her eyes um you know having done
it a bunch suddenly it's like
oh yeah this is kind of neat but i have
to keep like reminding her
she's like i don't feel worthy of this
and i was like why i was like [ __ ]
you watched
movies you watch tv are all those
[ __ ] people worthy
no there's a lot of stupid [ __ ] out
there
why can't we make some stupid [ __ ] you
know she's like you're right let's make
dumb things
i was like now you're a smith
uh if i if i guess what it is will you
tell me if i got it
after the show okay was it garbage pail
kids
holy [ __ ] how did you know
no not at all all right that's all
that's the only guess what a weird
random guess
i know right why did you pick that i
have no idea
it's like i've never even mentioned them
before or something like that where i'm
like you know what i want to do before i
leave this world
garbage pail kids
uh i i had was it this week last week i
can't remember
but i also i too went through that
process where a company came to me and
they were like
hey so we're taking a run at rebooting
this particular piece of
ip my least favorite two initials
just because it sounds so clinical it
does it really takes like your favorite
your childhood heroes and reduces them
to
you know a [ __ ] serial number it's
[ __ ] widgets once you say ip it's
like no this is ip stands for
intellectual property
for those following along who are like
huh yeah so this was like a year-long
process of me kind of
it started the top of the pandemic of
hey would you like to take a swing at
this and i said well yeah all right i
can find a way in and i found a way in
that i loved because
to spend time on it you have to find a
way to love it true you have to find a
way to invest yourself that's how we're
breaking down garbage pail kids i'll
tell you right now
i love the shitty one um and so yeah i
spent a year on this thing and like
refining the pitch and the proposal and
what are the episodes gonna feel like
and who are the characters and
and you're building a world that can
hopefully sustain a television show yes
and then you know i i deliver the pitch
to the guys who run the production
company and they dug it to hell and they
laugh the one guy who you know
it's a laugh you would recognize if you
heard it in the world i made him laugh
and it's like that makes me happy that
guy is that makes me happy yeah yeah
making funny people laugh
as a not funny person is my uh is my
raison a lot of people thought you were
very funny last week when you were
[ __ ]
skywalker drunk
well that was our song
another bottle for my friend
more of your piss wine please um
no it's delicious wine george it's it's
cool it goes whoa
piss wine [ __ ] you you broke nate's
heart um
yeah and and so made the guy laugh then
it was going up to the studio
and we were gonna hear like it's either
they're gonna love it they're going to
not love it but
we feel very confident in this right
studio didn't love it
and so that's a year's worth of work and
just and said no
and said no it was concluding with the
other guy including with the other dude
who would have been attached to it who
makes things that go
that go that's the thing that i'm most
surprised by because in my mind
like you know like i was i remember i
asked jj at one point man i mean can i
name drop from
step aside by all means i know jj abrams
no
um at one time i was i was like saying
to him i was like man like i
i ain't like you or i could just walk in
and be like i want to do a show and they
do the [ __ ] show
and he's like you think that's how it
works for me i was like yeah man look
how many shows you got he's like you
know how many shows
i pitch he's like the difference between
the amount of shows i get to make and
the amount of shows that i go on their
pitch is vast
and that's when i realized i was like oh
[ __ ] it's a game of odds it's not like i
always thought it was merit
like you walked in then they're like
you're the guy that made clerks here's a
show
you know instead it's just like pitch
like [ __ ] crazy so i remember hearing
like he implied he never said like
you know i know what it's like to lose
kev but his implication was
they don't make everything he wants to
make and to hear
that you went in with that guy who's got
juice and gets things made yeah and to
hear a studio is like
nah makes me go like oh i guess you know
[ __ ] i didn't miss anything
it's not me it's them yeah so it was
just it was just a year
yeah you know that now it's just a dead
end what do you do with it
it is there's a folder on my computer
this is called
inactive and so all of the things that
like all right i took around that didn't
work that's a
that's a book that i had already written
that either went or didn't go it's
it's the the the island of misfit toys
right of my
hard drive and so it just goes in there
like if something happens later on if i
get the call it's like
hey man it's back on then i pull that
from inactive and back into active and
then it can go and if not
can it be repurposed or is it very
specifically a thing it's very
specifically a thing
i had i had that recently where we
pitched a thing and um
it was first i pitched it at like one
place
and they were like holy [ __ ] we love
this and i was like thanks and they're
like we want to do this instantly and
we're going to find out like if the
character is
spoken for elsewhere in the company and
then they came back
like it is spoken for someplace else in
the company but they don't have plans
for it
and they're very excited to hear your
plans so it's like right on and they
were like look
if they say yeah this is happening and i
was like [ __ ]
and you hear that all the time in this
business and [ __ ] so i was like all
right right on
and we pitched and the people that we
pitched to
were like it's dark
and i was like well i mean you know but
it's also funny and they're like yeah
but it's dark
and so they didn't go for it and it
[ __ ] died there
so rather and it was for another thing
that somebody else owned
but i had brought enough to it where i
was like oh this will totally work
without their [ __ ] thing so now uh me
and andy mckelfirst were the ones that
went in there with the pitch repurposed
it into this
uh comic book that we're doing so we're
on issue three right now captain rip man
gonna draw it and stuff
but it was too good an idea to let go
and it was predicated on their ip
but all i had to do was be like well i
just changed this this this and you
would never [ __ ] know it's not like
you look at it and be like
um it's a [ __ ] invisible girl
you know or something like that would
like they got that over at marvel man
it's invisible one can't have it
no it's it's far enough away from what i
was applying it to where it'll actually
fly where it does fly i mean here's one
i can talk about because i know how
frustrating it is when we're just like
here's the thing
with a company based on a thing i'll
tell you what mine was it was the
question
ah i went in and pitched a version of
the question that i was told was too
[ __ ] dark
can you believe that [ __ ] i mean because
we pitched the question
yes and it was dark then it seems that
that's an answer you're never going to
get
you're right i don't know why i keep
trying because any time i'm anywhere
near a warner brothers thing ever and
they're like what do you want to do i'm
like you know what you guys should
[ __ ] do
the question i've been doing this [ __ ]
literally for 20 years i've been begging
people at warner brothers to make a
question i'm not even like i gotta do it
i'm like
just [ __ ] do it it's amazing and
stuff so we
this was the closest i ever got like
where hbo max was like oh my god we'll
totally do that show you just got to
make sure that they want to do the show
as well and oddly enough i'm not going
to dish too much but the other place
like i know people there so it's not
even i was dealing with strangers i was
like literally dealing with some
with some buddies but uh it was so it
was kind of weird
that it all went away but yeah it was
the question here's a question and then
i was like i got to that point where i
was like i'm [ __ ] tired after 20
years
of trying to make the question just go
make your own [ __ ] thing you know
where i got that
robert kirkman on our own [ __ ] show
he talked about like working at marvel
and he was like look it was fun but
i bolted because i'm like why am i
giving them all my best ideas
he's going just because i love these
characters so much like they i'm
hostage to my nostalgia he's like all i
have to do is cross the street put new
names on these stories and they're mine
and i was like that's [ __ ] smart man
so like
that's what we did as well and i
remember it was some like
twitter q a that somebody had asked me
it's like if there's anything you could
adapt what would you want to do
and like a [ __ ] i said uh i want to do
the secret of nim
and they were like really like yeah [ __ ]
yeah like secret of him
is like game of thrones level
storytelling if you treat it right
you know just without all the [ __ ]
sex
says who
[Laughter]
so whatever just [ __ ] one tweet like
father like son
mice [ __ ] how do you think that's the
secret of mine
you think there are so many mice um
and so like that was it [ __ ] 180
characters i fired off into the world
and then this producer
who i guess follows me like dm me like
are you serious about that
i was like yeah i'm serious about that
i've loved that [ __ ] the movie since
i was a kid
and that movie is dark as [ __ ] and
science and
rats and ethics and sword fighting and
magic that's all
badass do that and he's like well i'm uh
i'm currently talking to some of the
people who have the rights
and and we're trying to make a thing
with it do you want to talk and i was
like [ __ ] yeah i want to talk get on
phone with him
well not coffee with him this is when
you could have coffee with people right
and like went out to coffee and i just
[ __ ] talked for like a half an hour
about what i would do with it he's like
great
two weeks later uh can you be on the
phone in 10 minutes with don bluth
who directed the original movie in 1982
yeah i was like [ __ ] yes i can get on
the phone with don bluth
who is and i'm always concerned when i'm
getting on the phone when i'm talking to
the originator about a thing that i want
to [ __ ] with
right and and as a person who's made
things i understand completely how you
get tight about that how you're like
well the way i made it was the way it
should be um but if you're coming in as
an adapter which is what i would be
right i would have to be able to take
liberties with it like the idea that i
have is bigger than what that movie was
it's bigger than what the novels were
and not better in any way just bigger
it's broader it needs embroidery on the
edges
and so to get on the phone with the guy
who you know is the godfather of it
and see how he would respond to me
saying no it's game of thrones
what's game of thrones all right well
sit down there's a lot of incest
um it's just like a secret of nim but
more rapey i don't know i like dragons
and
rape i guess yeah sorry um but like just
walked him through my ideas for he was
like no i totally see this like would
you
you know is it a sequel i'm like no it's
like a reinvention i think you need to
reintroduce an audience especially a
young audience yeah to what this is
and not that you have to be it's not
extreme like game of thrones but i'm
just talking about the fabric of that
world
the connections of that world right and
uh and more importantly the long game of
that world the long game the implication
there
is like oh we could keep going with this
yes there's the five year plan for what
the secret
of name or the rats of nym or the the
mystery of nim would be as it is based
on books right yeah
and uh and it's like okay that sounds
great good luck let me know if you need
me it's like well thanks don that was
exactly the answer that i wanted let me
know if you need me um
and so i was down to do it don bluth was
down to
grandfather it the producer was ready to
go for it
and mgm had the rights and they wanted
to make a movie
and we're like well the rights might as
you know they could lapse in the next
year and if they lapse i know the rights
holders and
we can go to town the rights came up to
be lapsed and mgm just re-upped and
they're convinced that it's going to be
a movie
and then it just dies like and i grant i
didn't spend a year on it
but i spent enough time and enough brain
power and dream
dream and you fell in love with it yeah
because if you're getting it you have to
down to talk about it he has to feel
your love for it
otherwise he's going to shut you down
he's just a [ __ ] wayfarer
that's the way the bluth rolls and [ __ ]
indeed
sounded like what your project needed to
rise was a little bluth chew
[Applause]
bluth chew
gets you hard as a mouse
the true secret of nymph is your
dicodemus not strong enough
um so i got the one dude to remember so
i can see
him yeah deep cuts that's why he worked
on it for so long pretty much make that
joke
deep cuts yeah yeah and these are like
sound like [ __ ] problems or it's like
oh you didn't get to work on some stuff
but
it's the game out here like we're of age
now where
and there's so much content and the
content has everything to do with
catching people
our age and younger so naturally so much
of what they're making right now
is very nostalgic driven so like we're
old enough where they're like you knew
this [ __ ] right do you want to [ __ ]
come play with it and it's
how they get you going because you know
i i got my own toys to play with [ __ ]
jay and silly bob could do [ __ ] till the
end of time and whatnot one day they're
going to space you watch
but but quarter mile at a time baby
that's true but the the idea of somebody
being like oh would you like to play
with this thing it's like oh yeah that
means something to me that came from
my childhood i used to watch that and
blah blah and they can suck you in like
that and then in order to like
make it good you have to invest yourself
emotionally and when you invest yourself
emotionally
like you become attached and you're like
this is going to be a reality and then
when it all comes crashing down you have
to quickly divorce yourself from it and
move on
it's a weird process but like you know
it's a lottery
you know i imagine it's not that
different on some level
from people that play to pick six every
night you know i used to work at quick
stop people come in be like here's my
lotto numbers and [ __ ]
and you know it's like living hope die
in despair
each and every time like where they'd
spend like 40 to 100
a day on lottery numbers and like they'd
come back and do it the next day
and you know same difference where i
told the kid i was like this ain't a
given
this is a lottery we go into a room and
we pays our money takes our chances
we hope that we walk out of there
[ __ ] winning but like
it ain't necessary it's necessarily the
case so
like one one out of every ten of those
will go yeah
if that and only to like like oh we'll
let you write a script
right and then it dies there and and
like the jj's and the
and the you know berlantis they're three
out of every ten
four out of every ten i've never wanted
to be somebody more in my life than greg
berlanti
i assume greg berlanti doesn't even walk
into the room he just touches the door
handle and they're like we'll take two
seasons
like the magic [ __ ] touch i saw him
working
they just announced he's working with
robert downey jr
huge that's huge i don't know if you
know the guy he's an actor
of some note i've heard tell but like
even he
like doesn't there's some shows he goes
on pitches that don't go like he's a
slugger he's an all he's a hall of famer
yeah but even the hall of famers are
batting 400.
could you imagine you walk in you like
greg berlanti is like i'm going to do
your show with you know like oh my god
i want to be so [ __ ] rich like the
show's gonna run for 10 years
and you're in the one room where they're
like not this time greg
because then greg's track record is so
good he could always be like
it was you
[Laughter]
i hope you didn't buy that boat but i
bought the boat already
oh good lord uh the other thing i did
this week is i watched uh the third
episode of a little television program
called loki oh that's right
let's stop lamenting about our jobs and
get back to our other job yes
we all watched loki didn't we right we
all did
okay if you haven't i don't feel like
you watch loki
oh no we're gonna spoil the [ __ ] out of
it man i'm sorry
kids if you haven't watched loki cover
yours at home if you're here in the bar
go to the bathroom um
loki had its third episode its third of
six
yes so we're at the halfway mark now yes
um
and it was an episode i feel like i
could have directed
because it was two people sitting around
talking to each other for most of the
episode i was like [ __ ] i used to do
that in a convenience store man i'm like
break me off some of that marvel money
it was very much my dinner with loki
it very much was right up my alley and
[ __ ] speaking of right up my alley they
finally said like this guy's bi as [ __ ]
yes never mind to buy frost [ __ ] buy
loki now everyone on the internet was
shocked but i'm like come on
[ __ ] he's british come on and also
he's like
he's [ __ ] loki the god of mischief
you know he'd be like take your dick out
you know [ __ ] run away you're like oh
[ __ ] i got fooled by the [ __ ]
god of mischief you know i just assume
he would [ __ ] everything because he
seems like like zeus kind of in
greek mythology turned into a [ __ ]
cow or even like a golden shower which
sounds way hotter than it was
yeah but uh but you know i just assumed
if you're like a
god if you're an immortal don't you just
[ __ ] everything i imagine like every
goddess like mick jagger
yeah who's just like you know what i
[ __ ] live this long i'ma [ __ ]
everything well wouldn't i is that do we
know that is that yeah no he's admitted
bisexual like he's
and he said he's like i [ __ ] it all
he's like why because
he's like cause i'm still alive and i'll
keep [ __ ] it all
he's been a rock star for 60 years you
think he just doesn't do
everything whenever he wants never
really thought about it same thing with
bully they're like why wouldn't i do
this
when do they have time to write songs
well thanks to blue chew not much
blue chew for the song in your dick
uh what'd you think of this episode they
better do some [ __ ] quick
not for nothing i'm in and you know i'll
watch it it's [ __ ] free every week
anyway and stuff but like come on man
move it along
yeah i've kind of lost the thread on
what
loki is trying to do which is i want an
audience for the timekeepers like
okay why did
and how is what you're doing going to
get you there you know and like and i
get that and i'm also beginning to sense
then i don't remember exactly when this
was being produced
but it's feeling like a covet shoot yes
because there's lots of
two people talking to each other with
nobody else around yeah and i want to
train
two people sitting on a table nobody
else around we're walking two of us on
this planet alone
like there's a lot of just two-hander
scenes i've been making coveted movies
my whole career man
no wonder i was ready for the pandemic
um but
yeah you're right i haven't thought
about that it is probably you know
filmed in the day and it was always like
it's owen wilson and it's hiddleston at
a table looking at files and it's owen
wilson and google about the raw
in an office by themselves like it's a
lot of just two people
we could silo these two big rooms two
people yeah
um you know and i started to get this
feeling
that this episode begins with we're in
an apocalypse right like we got to get
off this planet that's going to destroy
itself
a clever idea from episode two the idea
that this loki is hiding
in places where the world is about to
end so you wouldn't notice if you change
things around that's a good idea
and then it's a whole episode about that
right which felt like there should be a
lot more heat
to the world's about to end you hate me
and i hate you but we have to work
together to get off this [ __ ] planet
so we have to like rush and do things
and this was a very not russian do
things episode this was like a
let's just kind of get on a train and
talk for a while it was kind of
leisurely yeah there was a lot of
chatter he had enough time for him to
get drunk
yeah and like which i guess you would do
at the end of the world i'm sure but
still
if there was nothing else you could have
done you know and also like this loki
doesn't seem like the kind of dude who
would be so irresponsible
as to blow their cover with a kegger i
agree
you know and also how does he get drunk
like thor couldn't get drunk
yeah she's like i'm full well that
doesn't mean you're stupid
you're just full you know and and i
couldn't understand the limits of loki's
magic
like there are times when he could stop
towers from falling on him
and then other times when like couldn't
you just fly into the [ __ ] cockpit of
this ship
couldn't you not like why why doesn't
the magic do what you wanted to do when
you wanted to do it the falling tower
actually did like take me back because
i'm like i thought he was all about
illusions that's an illusion like you're
literally stopping
something from happening and stuff um
yeah they play fast and loose with those
rules
it was a bit of a snow piercer episode
wasn't it it was like it was like snow
piercers slash the defiant ones
yeah you know slash like this is where
they get to know each other
right you know and i was hoping for just
some of that acceleration like this
there could have been urgency to all of
this and it just felt like
okay how did it end let's see that's
never a good sign if like i watched this
only a few days ago and i don't remember
what the big cliffhanger was kind of
didn't have an ending because the ship
they were supposed to get on blew up
that was the ending and then it's just
like okay what do we do now
credits yeah they're like we're [ __ ]
credits yeah
you know so i mean listen i'm i'm still
i enjoy tom
hilson so much that i just like watching
him do [ __ ] i would absolutely agree
with that he's so charming i'll sit
there and watch it
yeah but it's just like and i felt this
way a little bit
as you may remember about one division
of just be what you're going to be
and tell me the kind of show you're
going to be and start moving
and start getting us there and one
division like was interesting and it's
oh well she's just in this weird place
more mysterious too because at least
you're as frustrated as you would get
they were still like doing a thing where
you're like oh this i've never
seen they're they're doing a sitcom like
it looks like the sitcom i grew up in
you don't really have that so much with
loki it's like all right well then we're
relying on the plot
yeah and so far the plot is it feels
like it's being spread out
so yeah i mean i'm again we're always
still in we're never not going to watch
these things
but i just kind of wanted to engage a
bit more with whatever it's going to be
about for real
you know and not just what seems to be
the the mission of this show is
we're giving you loki back in the mcu
and a loki who is chastened enough so
that he feels like the loki who died
in infinity war and i was like okay
that's a decent project i mean i'm not
crazy about death not meaning anything
in the mcu
you know because there's something nice
about a sacrifice something nice about
the
the gesture towards his brother like i'm
trying to save your life by doing this
thing which i know will
result in my demise right but i'm doing
this for you like loki had grown enough
to get the sacrifice and now that
sacrifice is kind of wiped off the table
you know and if we can start doing that
then does death mean anything
and if death doesn't mean anything then
what are the stakes for any of this
because it all seems to be life and
death
do you i know they've said there have
been leaks in the press based
on merchandise this is always the
achilles heel
of keeping [ __ ] secret is you know if
you're going to make tie-in merchandise
that should has to get made months in
advance
in order to do that sometimes they put
information on a package that wouldn't
be out there
otherwise and so they you know there's
lots of
incredible info out there about the
identity of uh
lady loki right um
i just wanted to say that okay i mean i
don't want to ruin for everybody but you
can go look it up online
like if you want which kind of indicates
who the character
may or or may not be yeah i'm hoping
that and in saying that i'm there's a i
have this weird
like wish i wish is too hard word
in episode one most touching moment of
the episode is him looking at the
flashbacks of his life the tape that
they're playing and he sees his mother
right what if that was his mom this
whole time
that'd be [ __ ] dope right if it
turned out to be freya somehow
that would be dope i'd roll a tear for
that [ __ ] then i'd be like you could do
[ __ ] 10 episodes on the train i don't
give a [ __ ]
we were wrong you know yeah
and that would make sense if only
because it then makes the rules so that
the
[ __ ] tva makes sense which because if
she if sylvie
you know sophia whatever her name is the
actress is playing loki
a variant of loki then the whole tva's
mission is
to erase and cauterize variances in the
timeline
immediately that's what they do they
show up the minute something goes wrong
and then they [ __ ] burn it all to the
ground they light a time bomb and walk
away so then how does this person who's
clearly a variant
grow up if at some point she was born
and that birth was the fracturing of the
timeline of the sacred timeline
they should have been there when she was
an infant and squashed it or they should
have been there with a toddler or
whenever at some point
in the john connor timeline they could
have gone back in time and fixed that
[ __ ]
but they never did and so then how
effective is the tva
if they let this thing slip well there's
a i saw a few articles online this week
positing that the tva
perhaps doesn't even exist it may be a
big ruse
it seemed like a very [ __ ] long way
to go we gave out a jacket last week
you know how could it be a joke it's a
[ __ ] gotta be for real
um so yeah like i'm i'm assuming because
so far all of these shows have gotten to
the point where it begins to make sense
or catch you emotionally see that's the
thing i'm like they they hit
they hit it in episode one i was like
yeah lean into that man [ __ ] like
make that guy miss his mom like that's
[ __ ] cool
and then the farther they move away from
the emotional underpinning that's where
i'm like get back to that because that's
what wanda vision had
that [ __ ] delicious grief you could
just taste in every episode and [ __ ]
her broken heart and falcon and the
winter soldier had
both two dudes [ __ ] in love with a
dead guy you know
um this one like you gotta give there
has to be an emotional pull
to make me give a [ __ ] about loki i like
him as a character and whatnot but like
that that hint in episode one i'm
looking for more of that and they didn't
have it really in episode two
and they definitely did not have it in
episode three so i'm hoping it kind of
comes back like
all great [ __ ] stories have something
to do with mom or dad
and in his you've got [ __ ] elements
to make it pretty powerful
yeah you know or if you're going to play
the i don't have any family left
then here comes his sister perhaps or
he's somebody who could be like a sister
yeah and so engage in that story because
they're not doing that
they're not doing that yeah yeah so like
if it feels family is this
you got me excited because is that what
they're doing and i was like no wait
you're doing that
stop it i want to watch mark bernardin's
loki
um but yeah like not to not to [ __ ] on
anybody because i know
they've got a plan the plan is at work
and the plan probably is not about the
loki show as much as it is
the multiversal experiment that marvel
is leading
up to do you think we see anything about
kang the conqueror
i mean there was that bit in the in the
first episode when they found that
[ __ ] spear in the ground that was
from 3000 a.d or whatever
you think that's meant to be him that
was supposed to be some like well that's
about when kang begins doing his [ __ ]
multiversal time travel [ __ ] and so
yeah you just got me re-excited for the
show i didn't i didn't know that was
gang really
and i think ravona the character that
yeah rob plays
was a is a kang kind of love interest i
believe
from the comics from the comics do you
think they're gonna do that so
introducing her here and the history
that she may or may not have with
owen wilson's mobius emobius might be
starting to fill in that story those
blacks this is the first episode where
we got a piece of information that the
people that work at the tva
were from earth previously yes because
owen wilson was like no we're all born
here and [ __ ] and then all of a sudden
this episode they're like no they were
all former earthlings
and they were all variants all of them
are variants
yeah i guess that's a crucial piece of
information so instead of being clipped
and erased they were all brought into
the tva to go to work so that means that
mobius was a variant as well what if
he's a variant of morbius
the living vampire stop making better
shows
i gotta go home and watch disney plus
um all right uh let's hear uh the
sound of uh applause and you can make it
as enthusiastic or unenthusiastic as you
like
how many people liking loki so far
[Applause]
how many people not liking loki so far
wow [ __ ] you mark i know
a bunch of scared [ __ ] y'all
can clap
that's brand loyalty right there man
that's kind of the way i feel too is
even like
if it was any other show that wasn't
marvel connected
would i still be like oh i'm there for
every episode and [ __ ] but since it's
got the marvel name on it i'm like oh
marvel can [ __ ] my mom and my wife i
don't care
my mom and wife were like marvel gets to
[ __ ] you how about that i'm like i'll
[ __ ] take it
[Laughter]
um shall we give away some [ __ ] let's
give away some [ __ ] kids we got
start with let's start you know what we
could start with this box ready well
first off
um how do we do it in an orderly way hey
banff man can you appear
bam give it up for bam
um i saw on the internet um in the
comments section
of last episode people were like what a
[ __ ] train wreck giving that [ __ ] out
and whatnot
but i imagine that was not fun for
people at home but everyone in the room
seemed to be having a good time
there's also a message in that [ __ ]
comment where the guy was like you
better go back to hockey jerseys man i
was so [ __ ] sad
but i between that show and this show
i've lost seven pounds
and thank that guy because if he hadn't
said something i probably wouldn't have
[ __ ] went back to it but after i saw
that i was like oh [ __ ]
i don't want to have to i want to if i
go back to hockey jerseys because i want
to choose to not because like i have to
and [ __ ]
so i can run in all the way um bamf man
how do we give [ __ ] out what if we uh
first
do you think that that guy just doesn't
like the color purple
like no because i've gotten that for two
years people like get that [ __ ]
stupid jacket off
stop wearing that joker jacket grow up
and chill but they say that about
everything i wear but
his comment definitely played i mean i
felt it before i went i was like that
night i was like man i [ __ ] feel
heavy and [ __ ]
and the dude just said the right thing
and that's that's my
like that was my inner voice like you
don't want to go back to hockey jerseys
and that dude [ __ ] voiced it and i
was like oh take that beak from out my
heart
but at first i was like [ __ ] him but
then i was like you know what thank that
guy because otherwise i probably
wouldn't have thought about it and [ __ ]
and now i've redoubled my efforts so
but i don't think it was a hey man i
think you look better in hockey jerseys
you know
i i want to live in your world jc where
everybody's that [ __ ] nice and [ __ ]
i'm sure i'm gonna get hockey jersey
comments after this show where people
are like jc
you want to take some of kevin's old
hockey jerseys oh [ __ ]
man no you look ripped you look
quarantine ripped man
like you spent all that time at home
being like you take care of the baby i'm
pumping iron
pumping another baby i'll push them up
give me some [ __ ] blue chew
how do how do we give [ __ ] was more [ __ ]
out
i had do we want to do it by age which
is how we did the question
do we want to pick an age like 37
how about i mean i i always want ooh
that's good that's on brand
i always want to do [ __ ] like you know
not everyone wants it
so you want to be like who wants free
[ __ ] but everyone wants free [ __ ]
so like you can't do it that way and
stuff um
it's against the law to ask them to
exchange a gift for uh
looking at a body part right like that's
[ __ ]
oh it's just barter there's no laws
against that would bring the list way
[ __ ] down man i'd be like free [ __ ]
like you gotta show your dick and i'm
like i'm out of here
um hmm now i'm on the spot
i gotta come up with something quick uh
bam
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we're alone i know where to go uh well
let's start with this
premium uh i got a months ago
[Applause]
is uh for cobra kai ladies and gentlemen
we all love cobra kai
uh and they gave out a gift box now the
difference between most gift boxes like
uh
the other day we had a bunch of
cardboard gift boxes very nice and stuff
and i urge people to take them
this one listen to this [ __ ] it's made
of [ __ ] wood
well i guess you got to be able to
[ __ ] chop it but why would you chop
something that's nice you could put weed
in here well it's
it's cobra kaya it is it is cobra kaya
uh we take the lid off and this lid is
gonna like the box itself is gonna
belong to somebody at the end of the
night ladies and gentlemen
hey nerd [ __ ] you no there are two kinds
of people in this world miyagi doe
people
and bad asses the choice is yours and
now you could wear it with pride
to score all the hottest babes or
hottest dudes if that's your thing just
take a photo in your sweet new
reversible
dojo jacket and send it to the internet
for cobra kai series
uh i hear it helps if you hash brown it
hash brown it's supposed to be you know
uh
[ __ ] scentsy lawrence uh because he's
not
hip enough uh so use team cobra kai and
team
miyagi doe depending on which way you
swing
then sit back relax and raise your tall
boy to a new year
and a new season of cobra kai oh yeah
here's a little free advice for 2021
from
uncle johnny don't be a [ __ ]
um cobra kai
season three was dazzling uh can't wait
for the beginning of uh
season four which i guess they're
shooting right now right mm-hmm um
so what did you pull out we see uh
pulled out the jacket
and then two bandanas right on
headbands uh all right how do we do it
what did we do trivia i've got a tr uh
trivia a karate kid trivia question
let's see if anybody knows it first so
how about how
the first person that yells first person
uh yeah first person to yell it out
all right let's see it's not ralph
macchio uh he's pre-answering that's a
good idea
ralph macchio rav macchio [ __ ] the uh
the song at the end you're the best
yes was originally not written for
karate kid what was it for
it's rocky whoever got it
all right who did it you're getting this
right here
just the headband yeah yeah
we got a lot of [ __ ] give me a box no
way
let's break it up you break it up ah you
get the headband congratulations look
right in that camera and be like
they [ __ ] got my head covered
well done give it up for him he's a
winner ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
so that was the miyagi doe what is that
called the thing you put around here
the headband uh is it called a headband
i'm calling it a headband
this one is for cobra kai itself ladies
and gentlemen so
where's your next question oh man it
doesn't have to be cobra
it doesn't have to have one good one it
doesn't have to be cry kid it could be
literally anything
uh okay this is
totally random does anybody know but
it's a
sci-fi bar does anybody know who
directed the movie
three men and a baby i do
who said that did you get it
right here you said letter nimoy you're
right get on up here man
you take that headband you look in that
camera man and you say [ __ ] leonard
nimoy
yeah um all right man quality item
coming up here not that the other two
weren't but this will keep you [ __ ]
warm
it's uh strike heart strike first strike
hard no mercy
jacket um and it will come with the
switch
to the other side is also miyagido oh is
that right so it's both sides
both sides oh my god man it's [ __ ]
reversible jacket so it's not only fun
it's functional as well
um all right you got to come up with
another question jc okay uh
leonard nimoy that's [ __ ] one track
mine man
leonard nimoy uh had a
semi-famous song about another big
franchise
[Applause]
whoever got it the ballad of bilbo
baggins oh my god give it up he won
[Applause]
take your reversible jack of that card
you look in that camera and he said i
love cobra kai
give it up for him ladies and gentlemen
he's a winner
[Applause]
and now to grand prize ladies and
gentlemen you could put so many things
in this box
if we ever get it closed i don't want to
pinch your hands there you go
look at this goddamn box quality product
as if
they had to spend this much money to
convince anybody to watch such an
amazing show
uh the cobra guy box how do we uh give
him a question
okay uh in the animated lord of the
rings
movie yeah legolas was played by what
star wars actor voiced by what star wars
actor
it is not mark hamill not mark hamill
banff man
is shaking his head no who somebody said
it
close
i i i know we still don't have the right
answer
anthony daniels anthony daniels
you played legolas anthony daniels
voiced legolas in the lord of the rings
animated movie
well that's useful information man give
it up for banff man that was good
come get your box fox
[Applause]
look at this [ __ ] fine piece that's
what you get for knowing useless
information you take the box you look at
the camera and you tell them what you're
gonna do with that box
[Music]
yeah there you go give it up for him
ladies and gentlemen he won
[Applause]
uh who needs a t-shirt manscaped large
t-shirt yeah
bam well done people really win uh we
did this on the show a couple weeks ago
it's the uh aim box the advanced idea
mechanics
uh from the good folks who make uh uh
modoc
the hulu show uh inside there's a bunch
of [ __ ] so
we'll give out this [ __ ] right now there
is a
aim uh welcome new recruit looks like
probably a blank book yes
blank book who wants bam
book you're a winner give it up from
ladies and gentlemen
uh this is an aim stress ball oh i saw
that hand go up to all you
oh [ __ ] what right between their heads
this is why i never get invited out for
first pitch give it up for him ladies
and gentlemen he caught the ball somehow
this is one of them modoc slash aim like
oh
cup yeah yeah over here this guy
i see you so i am i'm not gonna throw
you come on up man you gotta give some
love to the wings man all right so we'll
do that
you do the next one i'll do the next one
give it up for everyone ladies and
gentlemen
who wants an aim lanyard aim lanyard
with the badge bam and uh
this ladies and gentlemen a can cozy
a modoc can code right back there
it went the other way uh is that
everything in the box and then ladies
and gentlemen
a sweet ass box who wants that yeah come
on up you get it man
it's got a hinge in everything well done
my friend well done
thank you you won kevin smith's box
and then the rest i guess we used to
play later on and i had another box
another crate from last week you had
like a sweatshirt and a couple of uh
razors and [ __ ] in there
oh that's right we have a lot of
manscape stuff too yeah do i want to
give it away now
i can run and get it i don't know i mean
for the for q and a for q a yeah
all right yeah that's right later on you
can win a ball trimmer ladies and
gentlemen so
don't get too drunk stick around okay
kids
uh now we get to the fundamental part of
the show uh why everybody
tunes in because uh we cover the news
man mr mark bernard used to cover the
news
[Applause]
and the only time he ever [ __ ] with the
news is for yous
so give it up for mark bernardin he
brought you the news man
what what has happened in the past few
days since we've done a show
uh is anybody in here a supernatural fan
wow show ran for 15 years and there's
eight people who watch it
uh well it's it's back kinda and uh
and one of those winchester boys isn't
happy about it um
supernatural one of the most important
series in the history of the cw
is uh planning a company a show that was
not just a cw show
they started on the wb wow that's how
old that [ __ ] show is they were like
there with the [ __ ] everybody doing
the wp
[Laughter]
wow the michigan j frog dress yes
absolutely so they made it a long time
man [ __ ] the super
supernatural elements couldn't kill that
show [ __ ] switching networks couldn't
kill that show
and those brothers are bond in love mark
those [ __ ] winchesters they would
never betray one another they [ __ ]
love
one another they put a house right next
to each other they take care of things
private jet they own together the two
actors that play them man i can't
live happily ever after amen is that
right uh it totally is kind of
because the winchesters which is this
new prequel which is
going to take place about sam and dean
winchester's parents
uh it's in development by jensen ackles
with his wife and he's one of the
winchesters he's one of the winchester
boys
um the other one is jared padilecci yes
who it turns out had never heard about
this show
until the press release dropped
and went on the twitters and was like
dude
happy for you wish i heard about this
some other way than twitter
i'm excited to watch but bummed that sam
winchester had no involvement whatsoever
really yeah cause i mean you imagine
those two dudes know each other well
enough where the one good
call the other dude and be like hey man
what the [ __ ] but instead he went public
yeah
and like the one dude that jared
pedolecki dude he's got a show on the
the cw walker texas ranger so like he
might be busy making money
um you know walking through texas i
guess whatever
but like hadn't heard about this show
and you'd think
yeah how do you i mean that how do you
not like walk next door and be like
hey man guess what i'm doing you want a
piece or you're both on the private jet
you don't think to look over the aisle
and be like i'm gonna get richer
what are you working on buddy nothing so
is the idea that the one boy is
sad that he was left out of this like
that's
is that why that tweet happened like hey
man why are you
[ __ ] making that supernatural money
and i'm not or just like
you know if jay decided he was going to
suddenly do what j
movie and didn't tell you
you'd be like hey
[Applause]
wait wait do jay and i have a jet
i i mean you got a tercel right you
should have like a 1982 toyota tercel
that is that is always the most
impressive part of that story to me is
that the supernatural
boys um i learned this when i worked on
like flash and supergirl because they
all shoot up in
vancouver and it's all part of the cw
but you know the supernatural
after the first two three seasons was so
popular at the conn circuit and they'd
be like we want the winchesters here and
[ __ ]
and when you shoot those shows you shoot
like five day weeks
but your fifth day is usually friday and
it goes in till like saturday morning so
they'll usually do it as a split we'll
call you in at five at night
and then you wrap five saturday morning
so that [ __ ] with their ability
to ever go to a con and so cons were
like we'll fly you out on a private jet
and they're like [ __ ] yeah let's do that
so they started flying on a private jet
to cons that khan's provided for them
only so they can get them there you know
in the nick of time and stuff based on
their shooting schedule and apparently
as the story goes those two boys like
sat on that
jet after jet and they were like what if
we bought the jet
and then we just charged these cons to
like take us there instead of them
hiring a plane they can hire
our plane to bring us there and all of
those [ __ ] cons they went to
paid for a [ __ ] jet man wow in that
impressive that's
[ __ ] fandom right there man like the
dudes own a jet because
people like i got to take a picture next
to jared you know or
[ __ ] was the other guy's name uh jensen
jensen yeah like jj oh i want to be
between jay and jay i want to be a jj
sandwich so i'll [ __ ]
i'll pay whatever it costs and that
helped get them like that jet
i've been doing jane's silly bob [ __ ]
for like nearly 30 years
like we fly coach so like
that supernatural fandom is pretty
damned impressive man um
so yeah it's it seemed as if there was a
schism in the supernatural fandom
sounds like it for all of like 24 hours
and then
you know maybe one of them was like a
dark winchester from an alternative
universe
yeah a variant yeah
went on twitter the you know friday and
was like the show is early in the
process with miles to go
we've traveled a lot of roads together
and sometimes those damn roads have
bumps
bumps don't stop us once brothers always
brothers
uh was that good enough for you cw brass
because i don't want to [ __ ] with your
money either
throw in a hashtag family while we're at
it man just to make it [ __ ]
clear well uh all's well that ends well
i guess yeah and if you're a fan of the
show you're going to get more of the
show
so i saw some people online today the
big hardcore fans of the show uh have an
issue with the show because the show is
going to tell the story of the father
and the father father was a 70s father
so like when we were kids like you'd get
hit with a belt and [ __ ] like that you
could spank a kid
apparently most people today don't hit
their kid i don't have my kid you know
your kid obviously and [ __ ] so that's a
thing of the past
but in the lore and again i i don't
watch supernatural so if i'm offending
anybody i don't mean to but in
what i read what i gathered based on
reading twitter this morning was in the
lure
their dad is abusive or what some would
consider abusive when i read what they
said was abusive i was like
oh then my dad was abusive you know that
was just 1976. yeah you got [ __ ]
spanked for [ __ ] and whatnot
but um some people are like i don't want
to watch a show about like their abuser
who made them
what they were and like we watched 15
seasons or whatever of like
them being the product of like their
crazy dad or something like that i
thought that was kind of interesting so
you know how they write that out how dad
was possessed by a demon
[Applause]
which is why they became demon hunters
when they grew up because
[ __ ] it's the original sin
hire this man it's a good idea
um well glad that it all worked out for
the boys but it's kind of crazy that one
didn't mention it to the other at any
given time because it's not like he had
the idea and that minute called the cw
and they're like yes
we're telling deadline today it would be
akin to like you finding out that i do a
show crosstown
on like [ __ ] wednesday nights called
fat man beyonder
thought you'd kept the secret from me
for like seven years and you're like hey
man
happy for you bro but you might have
mentioned it
like i got a flat tire and stumbled into
a bar and there you are behind the bar
with some other dude
it's like who the [ __ ] is that black guy
i'm like i know more than once [ __ ]
tracy jordan is back there
son of a [ __ ] who's that black guy
i'm the captain now what other
[Applause]
that was without skywalker wine well
done
um what other news man god i wish i was
supernatural rich could you imagine
being supernatural
seasons of a show dude nothing goes 15
seasons there's not like [ __ ]
as the word chicago and or dongdong in
the beginning
budgets for shows go down too the longer
they're on the air yeah but that show
was so like since it had been up and
running for 15 years they had amortized
every cost so the show was like
incredibly
inexpensive to produce the biggest
expense
from what i understood was them was
their salaries because they'd been on
the show for
so long that whenever they re-upped they
re-upped pretty damn powerfully and
stuff but it was you know i know there's
a huge army of supernatural fans
but for most cats like when you said hey
he was a supernatural fan and there
wasn't a lot of
reaction most of those cats are always
surprised to find out like how [ __ ]
successful that was i told my wife about
jet story because i went to work on
flash
and they told me that story up there and
so when i came home i told my wife i was
like you know
[ __ ] the boys from supernatural has a
jet and she's like i should be [ __ ]
the boys from supernatural
i'm tired of this flying coach [ __ ] and
she did
no uh what other stories do we have uh
j.j abrams is adding to his dc comics
adaptation
portfolio with a show called madame x oh
thank god you didn't say the question
i'd be like ah
no wonder they were a little tepid in
the room
now hbo max and jj are developing madame
x um
with a writer executive producer named
angela robinson
who worked on hung and true blood um
and do you know what was the first one
besides trouble
remember hung with the punisher oh with
[ __ ]
yeah horny horny patty was one of the
characters
tell me about horny pants i was
apparently a deep cuts fan
um are you familiar with madame x as a
character madame xanadu i believe is her
full name
a little bit but not deeply familiar
she's like kind of from the zatanna
zatara world
yeah the character also known as nima or
nimmuei
is a clairvoyant who uses tarot cards to
tell the future she can levitate objects
teleport
and banish minor demons she's also
immortal
thanks to a deal she made with death um
and so apparently she was also in swamp
thing where she was played by
gerald prescott in the swamp thing tv
she swamp tv show
so basically jj is coming for all of
your toys
um that well once you bring jj over to
warner brothers and pay him a king's
ransom
like yeah i'm sure that he whatever he
wants to do they're probably going to be
like yeah let's give it a shot
i'm sorry somebody wrote on the
revelation figure
please sign both and i don't know what
that means there's only one figure is
this a trick question
so then kevin kevin conroy i believe it
would be like please
both sign oh which you did right my bad
[Applause]
anyway
wow such what a waste of time that was
any who uh okay please
both there it is you got that
please sign on top of the pops oh i've
never done that before you mean on the
who's are these it's on the tops that's
a new thing
[ __ ] hey well done mostly it's on the
window and [ __ ] all right back to you
what's the next one
whether wither the news mark how many of
you folks were interview with the
vampire fans
the movie or the books or either or both
i like the movies you like the movies
um it turns out that amc after spending
a
king's ransom to get the rights to 18 or
so of anne rice's books
is now officially making an interview
with a vampire tv show
oh yeah that makes sense right yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah there's plenty of lestat
and uh louis stories to tell um and so
they're going for the dude who did perry
mason
a fellow named roland jones i'm going to
say his name is roland not rolling
because roland sounds cooler
will be the showrunner for the first
season it's gonna be an eight-episode
show
that's going to premiere on amc and amc
plus their streamer
in 2022. no word if
if the immortal tom cruise will be
returning
as let's stop uh in a world where you
know i guess the walking dead is kind of
going away right sooner or later
in some fashion like the main the the
mother ship is gonna
this upcoming season is a final season
there's like three or four spin-offs
fear the walking dead is still going
and they're launching any number of
things out of it so we're never going to
be in a walking dead less
universe i don't think um but yeah they
need stuff
and so this this seems like good stuff
to do vampires are cool
they're always cool costume dramas are
cool like the crown is the highest rated
thing on and bridgette and his israeli
thing on
bridgeton with vampires dude um a show
where everybody [ __ ] and drinks blood
i'll watch that
yeah i see no downside
at all to the [ __ ] blood drinking
show like true blood but at cosplay
convention
exactly exactly what else we got um
apparently they're trying to break
harrison ford did you
yeah you can't you can't [ __ ] ruin
harrison ford didn't they ever see
regarding henry you could put a bullet
in his head and he'll [ __ ] bounce
back
uh yeah once again he got hurt 78 year
old man is rehearsing for a fight scene
and like throws out his shoulder and
people are like how'd that happen
it's like what what are you [ __ ] nuts
remember last time they tried to take
his leg off with the millennium falcon
this time like go for his [ __ ]
shoulder leave this poor man alone
i mean he's a ripped [ __ ] 78 year old
but he's still 78 years old man like
take some care
with indiana jones what are you missing
somebody asked me to sign in silver but
i
is somebody have a silver pen you got
one bring it up
i think it's adorable that you assume i
always walk everywhere with a silver pen
you don't i'm like i only use this one
for special people
thank you back to you yeah so
[ __ ] they're now shooting around
gimpy harrison ford
as he recovers from spraining a wing
while practicing
to throw a punch i'm reducing it to its
bare minimum
i'm sure it was very elaborate stunt of
him like getting out of bed
does it put him out of commission like
do they have to shut down for a minute
or no
they're not shutting down not the way
they did with with force awakens i think
because he like
really [ __ ] up his leg on the
millennium falcon big time and you know
he's the star of this one so
they're they're very gingerly shooting
around him for now while he recovers
this is the one that has flea bag in it
right the fleabag lady what's her name
it has phoebe wallabrae bb walla bridge
yeah she's got three names
yeah mads mickelson they can fix this so
easily man they could just keep the shot
where he hurts his arm
and then she could just turn the camera
and be like he [ __ ] up and then go
back
she's there ace in the hole nice um
did you know did you know
that salma hayek was almost in the
matrix
no yes in the in the sliding doors
matrix edition
sam hayek was almost cast as trinity
oh wow she was one of three content one
of four contenders for the
for the role carrion moss who got it
salma hayek
jada pinkett smith was also in the fight
she was in the second one
um they rolled her up as niobee yeah and
a mysterious
fourth actress that nobody knows um but
yeah somehow
mentioned while she was promoting the
hitman's wife's bodyguard movie
that uh she was like yeah i'm fr i'm
flexible and i'm agile but i'm lazy
and so she failed a physical test is
that what it came down yeah
i would have assumed like carrie and
moss's performance is incredibly
understated um and i was like maybe sama
couldn't
understate it no understated i don't
think so i think she's very
like present and stuff like that but is
that why because she couldn't do a
[ __ ] bullet time flip according to
her she said was her inability to pass a
physical test that lost her the part
i never really went to the gym they said
you have to run i go to where i couldn't
even go around the room once
they never called me again after that
day
wow yeah that movie came out in 99
so did dogma ah i think i know the movie
she did instead
what'd she like and she regrets it to
this day
she went to her agent find me something
else yeah as long as i don't have to run
here's the thing what about the catholic
church fine
whatever um wow man [ __ ] it's always
cool when you hear stories like that
like who could have been who and she
wasn't will smith supposed to be agent
neo and then they go wanted will smith
ronillo and he couldn't understand the
script
he was like i don't know what this is
about not that he's stupid he just
couldn't get it
and it's a leap of faith that script is
very very [ __ ] dense
and all like what's a nebuchadnezzar and
why am i on this thing and what what's
real and what isn't real and he's like i
just don't get it and
then jada was in it jada was also up for
the same movie but then wound up being
in the second one wound up in the second
it's been made for awkward conversation
at the dinner table
hey remember that [ __ ] thing you
passed on idiot
i'm in it now i'll save the [ __ ]
family
do you get it now yeah go enjoy your
summertime
anyway anyhow uh i think the the last
story is the life story
yes last story of the day is that george
martin it turns out was also unhappy
with the way the game of thrones tv show
ended
george rr martin yeah yeah i mean i
never thought he was very shy throughout
the whole process of being like look
they do [ __ ] that i'm not into
so i can't imagine he was delighted with
the end of that show
yeah was he like look they should have
really [ __ ] up seriously her dying in
a [ __ ] like falling roof it was a
real cheat
i wanted to see her head getting off by
a dragon
george r.r martin
hashtag whoops yeah i thought that was a
missed opportunity one of the most hated
characters
in television history and they're like
how'd she die man she ripped apart by
the dragons and [ __ ] like nah the roof
fell on her
yeah she died in the arms of somebody
she loved you're like what
who gets that yeah that ain't fair uh
but yeah he
he kind of wishes he was like by the
time i sold the show to them
i was four books ahead you know and by
the time the first show came out
i was like all right i got one bug i
like got it right left and i'm i'm
making good progress
and then they just outpaced him yeah and
so he kind of regrets the fact that like
well i
i wish i'd stayed ahead of the books uh
i wish i'd stayed ahead of the series
his direct quote is when they began the
series i had four books already in print
the fifth one just came out as the
series was starting
i had a five book head start and these
are gigantic books i never thought they
would catch up with me but they did
they caught up with me and passed me and
you know that made it a little strange
because now the show was ahead of me
and the show was going in different
directions
he wrote that press release on a series
of hundred dollar bills that he was
going to throw away
totally um you know jeeves deliver this
to the press will you
throw the rest away i mean he fed the
writers room with bits and pieces of
information especially regarding his
intended ending for the series
but without the following books to
support them game of thrones writers
added things that snowballed over time
which resulted in a finale that felt
both rushed and disappointing
um and he was like i'm still working on
the book so you'll see my ending
when it comes out oh a little shade
there
yeah here's how i would have i would if
i was him i would have been like you'll
see the real ending
soon um wow good for him he kept his
mouth shut for a good year how long has
been
two years two years two years that's you
know what
like i respect that even though the fact
that he probably ate him out inside and
he [ __ ] he just
was like look i took the money i'm not
gonna be a jerk i'm gonna wait two years
then i'm gonna be a [ __ ] jerk about
it
i'm gonna wait two years and take more
money because he signed a new deal with
hbo and he's now directly overseeing all
of these shows
he called his account he's like did that
check clear hey i hated the [ __ ] end
of that show
[Applause]
i could identify with that um what else
we got that was the last piece of news
that was the last piece of news my
friend look at that nobody died this
week or anything thank god
yeah i don't think so did anybody die
our childhood's still intact all right
give it up for mark he got the news for
you
news is is the chat saying that i left
something out
yeah let's hey bamf man what's going on
in chat for the last year
me and mark were always so preoccupied
with chat because that was our only
audience
uh how are they in chat one of us was
preoccupied with chat
i was i was like what are they saying
we've uh we've got a lot of
international people
since the show's in the afternoon so uh
shout outs from scotland south africa
some dude from the north pole shut the
[ __ ] up greetings from the north pole
are you [ __ ] serious i asked how
heavy is he
i asked him if it was santa claus and he
didn't get back to me so
that's a yes that's a bingo
a lot of people bummed that uh mark
hasn't gone full wino
hey man there's still a bit of the show
left let's break out a bottle and
get them all drunk send them home in the
afternoon all like hey
i'm the king of this [ __ ]
we'll take out some garbage king of this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i will george dewitt you know
sometimes they send us like the manscape
trimmers he said that
blue chew is definitely something that
they should hand out samples at the end
of batman beyonce i think that's a good
idea man
i think that'd be an amazing way it's a
communal way to start the show
we all pop a blue juice and by the end
of the show we're just like this
and then the next week we get lots of
like would you stop handing out blue
cheese
from [ __ ] wives who were like i
didn't want that
eight people died because of the batman
beyond podcast
the still that is a good idea and then
uh r mixon's
craziest theory said that comicbook.com
will have the
headline mark bernardin wanted to turn
secret of nim into a rat
sex-filled game of thrones
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm going to spread that rumor myself
after the show
so those those are some highlights glad
that they're having a good time
um all right we're going to get into the
kevin and mark
can you dedicate this to toy power
podcast
frank trent darren and ben um yeah it's
going to take a minute though
but i can do that this is a lot of words
but
they tell me i'm a writer um
shall we uh start yeah shall we start
the questioning are we gonna do it the
way we did it
the other day yeah we'll do it the same
as we did last time so the first
question will be like the
question that somebody asked but
somebody in the room wins something they
ask on the internet but somebody in the
room actually wins
and the person at home wins nothing
the [ __ ] is that
where'd that come from they gave you one
of those
you're gonna give that away i'll [ __ ]
take that
that's a hundreds hoodie you brought
quality prizes man i brought like the
cobra kai box and [ __ ]
wow man that's a prize worth winning i'm
gonna because i am older and i'm a river
to my people
but what it says to me is they sent you
that and you're like oh i'm not wearing
this
no
isn't that my style apparently not um
are both of us signing the he-man just
that
y'all [ __ ] are gonna be so
shorn by the end of this night we have
so much manscape to give away
they've sent us shavers and you know
ladies they're not just for men the
shavers work on anybody and stuff so
you'll enjoy them too even though they
say manscaped on them
um they have not come out with a woman
escaped line yet
oh [ __ ] i dropped a very old comic book
[ __ ]
it's worth oh it's static oh it's yours
oh
are we both signing static who who puts
static on the bar
[ __ ] hey man i mean i didn't write
that me neither but
i feel like i will deface it can i
borrow that
yeah you can look at this cover man it's
awesome it's him
outside of a temple
yeah sorry we got lost for a second
there forgot we were doing a show like
oh that's what we talk like when
nobody's around
just like look at this comic yeah look
at it that's cool
um all right jc shall shall we
start the questions yeah let's do it um
mark was talking about mick jagger
earlier so william and chat
wanted to know what the [ __ ] is this
whose is this
that is beautiful steven silver did it
[ __ ] gorgeous man so he has like the
batman detective comics 1000 that i
wrote a story on
but the cover is is uh blunt man
um as drawn by stephen silver
and he made it into this like gorgeous
little piece
that's [ __ ] dope man uh okay
uh okay so william and chat wanted you
guys
to cast your version of the beatles and
the stones
using characters from dc and marvel
okay whoa the beatles and the stones
using marvel and dc characters um
i don't know if i could do the stones
let's just do uh
that's a lot of people let's do uh mick
jagger and keith richards plus the
beatles
and the beatles so two bands but only
two in the one band
ignoring all the other rolling stones
all of whom listen to this podcast and
they're like they're gonna reference us
and then you hear you and they're like
[ __ ]
it's keith and mick again um all right
for the beatles
well all right should we should we back
and forth sure i'll go first
for the beatles fantastic four next
[Applause]
seems like an even swap you son of a
[ __ ]
uh all right for
for john the sandman
morpheus yes [ __ ] i og morpheus
uh because san man came before that
movie that's true yes well now the
the neil gaiman i like it i'm down um
i like your comic book so far i'm ready
to buy it uh let's see
for poll
eddie nigma the riddler himself
riddler himself so if paul doesn't like
john's lyrics he pulls out his question
mark gun shoots him in the [ __ ] face
that's a band um see for
george gotta be thoughtful young
um and quiet also a little like
silent bob please say something
silent bob no not at all he's not from
dc you can use jericho from the titans
he was quiet really quiet yeah very
quiet
or uh uh onomatopoeia thank you for that
man it's [ __ ] old-school fan there's
a
he was quiet jericho i'm going
onomatopoeia
oh i get to play i'm in your universe my
character
ringo
the drummer from planetary
oh there was a character named name the
drummer didn't make that [ __ ] up
so yeah those are my four not as
exciting as a fantastic four but [ __ ] it
um for mick and keith yes you can lead
on that one
uh for keith i do solomon grundy
because that [ __ ] will never die
fair enough all right
because he's eternal i was like because
he looks like him and
at first i was like he's kind of right
um all right that makes sense and then
what about mick
for mick uh yeah
lobo oh very nice
very nice for my mick jagger i choose
stan lee
oh he
loved loved and i'm not uh not
overestimating
loved saying that line in in mall rats
when he was just like
you know me and jagger used to have a
running contest last time i checked i
was way ahead
and i remember like after we did the
first take he was just like i met mick
jagger
and i was like oh right on man what's he
like and he's just like he gets way more
than i do
um okay and then who would be my keith
um
johnny depp no uh comic book character
dc comic book dc combo character well
really because my
my stan is my mick well stan also did
some just imagine dc
oh my god well done look at him so you
get a loophole yeah you pulled that out
um all right so then
did you say hell blazer john constantine
i'll take that
good answer that's fine nate gave that
answer give it up for nate well done
[Applause]
[Music]
okay it may be tepid applause but in my
heart it's [ __ ] huge nate that you
saved me with that answer
uh so that was the internet question
right so somebody gets something for
free in the room
oh yeah this guy over here is what the
oldest
he was the oldest oldest and
come on up get your prize what's in here
variety
how about this you get a hat and a
poster
how about this were you a fan of captain
america in the winter soldier
then you got yourself a [ __ ] brand
new cat from disney plus
and nate's artwork and hold on
hold on
oh [ __ ] what is it what's in it that's a
manscape kit
i need that yeah yeah you turned into
that camera
look at that wait wait come back come
back come back come back come back come
back
look into the camera and say i'm an old
guy i'm going to shave my balls
i'm gonna play that for my mom later on
tonight
she'd be like that's hot tiger um okay
now questions of folks here in the room
is that right jc that is correct
uh our first question comes from kate
kate
barrizzo berezo
come on up give it up for kate
look at that [ __ ] shirt that's an
excellent shirt kate
uh what do you got for us don't look at
the card look in my eyes
kevin no you can look at the card go
ahead i'm like direct eye contact okay
so i am a total normie who works in
north
non-profit management but i was so
curious to hear
what roles have your wives played in
supporting your
success and how can non-creative
partners support
their loved ones in pursuing creative
careers
what a great [ __ ] question it's an
amazing question
um my wife almost came to the show today
and she would have loved hearing my
answer but she didn't come so [ __ ] her
[Laughter]
um my wife uh i started my career before
i met
my wife so like um i i don't have that
story of like
we were struggling and she was like go
make clerks or anything like that she
came afterwards so she was like give me
the clerk's money
uh hell yeah so uh i've been with jen
since 98 so
we were making dogma when i met and
she's been around
since then um and she honestly
she made me a better writer um because
she introduced far more of a feminine
perspective
than i ever would have had in my work
and i was pretty femme you ask people in
high school
they'll tell you um and you look at my
early work it's not like
hard hardcore stuff it's very pro-woman
and stuff but you look at the work from
dogma forward
um and some people are like that's when
your career [ __ ] fell apart
a lot of that is inspired by jen i don't
get to jersey girl unless
you know i meet jennifer and stuff and i
wrote jersey girl as a valentine tour
when i gave her the script i was like i
wrote this it's about
us it's like my valentine to you and she
read the script and she was like
[ __ ] wife dies in the first half hour
she's like and then you marry liv tyler
and i was like yes yes
it seems the way um
so uh so yeah she's uh she's
informed the work uh a great deal let me
tell you a story though
um [ __ ] how do i do this god damn it i
can't without spoiling something all
right
i'm gonna try to step around it so i'm
working on this script with the kid as
previously mentioned and
birthday harley in the ass today is my
daughter's 22nd birthday
which i'm very happy for her but like
that's like as a parent you're like i
kept a [ __ ] thing alive for 22 years
like jennifer woke up this morning she
was like we did it man this fucker's
still alive and i was like yeah
um so anyway we're writing something
together and um
i because of my wife
and because of the influence that my
wife has played in my life being not
just my wife but the mother of a
daughter
you know everything was always like hey
man you got to think about the fact that
we got a daughter now and stuff
so sh so i wrote a thing in the script
with harley that was like um
i can't give the line away because it
gives everything away but it's the line
starts with every girl's uh blank and
then you put it in it's not it's not
not match game like every girl's a
[ __ ] hooker it's a
it's a very sweet line but if i say what
every girl is you'll be like oh my god
you're working on
this and we can't do that yet so i
included that line and as i wrote that
line
i felt so incredibly self-satisfied
because i was like
that's my wife's influence like were it
not for jennifer
i wouldn't have written that line and
i'm glad i did like i'm glad
it makes it [ __ ] better and i
couldn't wait for my wife to read it
and then my kid read it and my kid goes
you can't say that and i said why
and she's like because not everybody is
a girl don't you understand
and i was like well but i mean
but your mom would be so happy and
and she's like i know but like there are
non-binary people in the world you can't
just make it that simple dad
like she's been great for [ __ ] like that
i got blind spots for days man and this
kid
finds something like that so i told her
i was like you don't understand i was
like that was really going to impress
your mother
and my kid [ __ ] it without missing a
beat goes dad haven't you had enough sex
with mom
already i love that she knew that's why
i was at it i was like this will make
her happy and then she'll want to kiss
me
so yeah my wife definitely has
influenced me but now my
kid is kind of taking that role
over to some degree and i told jennifer
about it because i told her because i
told her pieces so i was like i wrote
this line she was like
i knew you always listened to me she's
like it's so good like i'm so proud of
you kevin i was like and then your kid
killed the [ __ ] line and she was like
what and i told her what it was and she
was like she's right i was like i know
so yeah my she's jennifer has um
one of my favorite things she ever did
in this life with me that we share
other than make harley together and
stuff like that uh professionally
speaking was
when i handed her tusk the script to
tusk
for her to read and you know first it
was like the first 20 30 pages
and she read it and she was like can you
come down here and talk about this and i
went down i was like what's up and she
didn't know anything about it she didn't
know we'd done a podcast me and scott
and i was in love with this idea of
making a movie about a guy who turns
into a walrus
so she read those first 30 pages she
goes what is this
and i hadn't made a movie for like three
[ __ ] years right so i was like this
is this movie
i'm working on she goes what happens to
this boy
and i was like nothing good
and and i was just like uh i was like
what do you think and she's going like
it's
i'm curious where it goes and i was like
all right i'm gonna go finish it and
she's like do it
so i went and finished it and i gave her
the script she read the whole script she
called me to head to the bedroom and she
was like
kevin this is the stupidest [ __ ]
script i've ever read in my life
and i was like thank you and she's gone
but it really holds together
she's going it's a total page turner so
like every step of the way when i was
like
oh no he didn't oh [ __ ] he did and she's
like i kept going like
i i really think you should make it and
i was like are you [ __ ] serious like
i haven't made a movie in three years
she's like yeah and i didn't imagine
this would be the one to bring it back
she's going but it's so [ __ ] bizarre
and she's going i
you know how much would it cost and i
was like i think it feels like a three
million dollar movie and stuff and she's
like do we have three million dollars
like
[ __ ] no if you wanted to have three
million of the bank you should have
married another guy from [ __ ] mall
rats named affleck you'd have a lot of
[ __ ] money
but you married silent bob so we're real
hand-to-mouth and [ __ ] and she was like
well what about the house could we
do a second mortgage on the house and
that [ __ ] blew me away
and i was like are you [ __ ] serious
like i think that would be
incredible like i would if i was alone
of course i would risk everything i have
on this idea
but like do you know how amazing it is
how metal it would be
to risk my future your future the kids
future
on this [ __ ] walrus movie that'd be
amazing so we got to make the walrus
movie so yeah she
she's always been super supportive you
know not i wouldn't even say the world's
biggest kevin smith fan like she likes
kevin smith but
the movies and [ __ ] like this is a
nightmare to her all these items sitting
here she's like oh you make so much crap
why do people buy this
i'm like you better [ __ ] be thankful
they do you got a roof over your [ __ ]
head
so she likes she likes me but she's like
the movie stuff she's
really really indifferent about kind of
like on jane soundbob straight back she
when i wrote the script like you know we
were barely
together two years at that point maybe
three or something like that two when i
started writing the script when she
first read it
so you know she knew me a little bit
certainly enough to have a child with me
but like she didn't know me know me as
she would come to know me over the years
and this was the first thing i'd written
while we were together you know she came
into my life while we were working on
dogmas this is the first screenplay i
wrote while we were a couple
and so i gave it to her and jay and
silent bob strike back is pretty much
what jay and son and bob strike back is
first draft was weird because they never
left the state of new jersey
they never went to hollywood everything
happened in new jersey they were making
good will hunting too
in new jersey like so but generally
speaking
almost the same movie so jennifer reads
the script and i've got a picture of her
sitting in like a hammock
wearing uh overalls reading the [ __ ]
script and uh after she was done i was
like what do you think
and she goes um it's cute it's a movie
for boys isn't it
and i was like well i mean i guess and
she's like yeah she's like yeah
that's what i feel like i feel like it's
a movie for teenage boys
and i was like thanks that sounds a
little condescending she's going well it
was
and uh she's gone well can i be in it
and i was like you want to be in this
teenage boy movie and she's like oh
kevin you put everyone
you know in the movie man you put your
best friends in the movie what about
putting
this best friend in the movie i was like
well jason muse is in the movie he's my
best friend and [ __ ]
and she was like you put me in this
movie if you ever want to [ __ ] again i
was like yes dear
and uh and so she wound up and jay and
sound bob check back so she
she's in the movies often times but like
like i have to drag her into it she's
never like ooh that was the only time
she ever showed enthusiasm
and then after that movie she was like
no i don't need to be in your movies
anymore and now i'm like oh now you
started you gotta [ __ ] do it
because you're free and cheap help um
what about you
uh lady bernard who comes from my neck
of the woods because she's a jersey girl
like my like literally like i could i
could have bumped into her two guys and
[ __ ] like that
bradley's um no i met my wife
i had i was out of college like three
years i was making
13 000 a year
which big money were you doing not a lot
of money
what were you doing i was uh i was an
editor at starlog magazine
and fango at the time making a hot 13k
year how old were you i was 25 years old
yeah but i would imagine
at age 25 you're like i'm [ __ ]
working at fangoria making 13 000. i'm
the king of the universe
i mean it's not bad but i was like still
living with my mom because it turns out
you can't move out while living in new
york on 13 000
fair enough um and so that's when she
met me
and so she absolutely was there for
everything for the
leaving star law going entertainment
weekly being an intimate weekly kind of
rising and then getting fired from
entertainment weekly and then
wallowing for a bit and so the for me
the biggest thing that
she has allowed for me and given me is
faith
because that's it's because she's not
of this world she's not a she's not a
creative person she's not in show
business she was in medical sales
before we had kids and so it was always
she would read things she was always
like my first reader
and she said this is pretty good and i'd
say thanks i don't think so yet but it
might get there
but you know when i would say things and
propose things like hey should we move
to la
you know why walk i want to try and give
this tv writing thing a
go and i can only really do it from la
the jersey girl was willing to uproot
herself
leave everything she knew behind and
come out here it's huge
it's it's massive when you when somebody
lives
dreams your dream for you that's the
best thing another human being could do
for
shy of maybe saving their life or
starting their life dreaming their dream
for them
is powerful because you can't most
people want to dream their own dreams
and [ __ ]
and so when you find somebody who's like
no i'll [ __ ] dream your dream with
you
that's that's the person you want to
spend your life with and hopefully you
feel the same way about that person as
well
and so faith that all of this would be
worth
something and belief that i was what i
thought i could be
and she thought i could be that too so
if if you are looking to support
somebody in your life who's creative
the thing they need more than anything
is to believe in themselves and if you
can help them do that
by believing in them too i think that's
the that's the mitzvah
that you can offer dear mark
thank you you want to do should we do
the
the giveaway at the end yeah we'll do it
after the
um yeah once we do all the questions
we'll figure out who wins what
i uh i'll i'll share my version of that
which is i'm sorry we don't hear you
unless you bam
bam there we go um i have uh
i had known i met jen which people have
heard me talk about a million times at a
rat concert
the house of blues on sunset strip and
uh
i was really into her and she just
wanted nothing to do with me
and uh five years six years later she's
like oh i want
i want to date that jc guy so she
started pursuing me
and i was in um i was interviewing at
lucasfilm and we had just gone to north
carolina to make tusk
right and uh and she's hitting me up and
hit me up and i was like look
like i'm i'm working with kevin on this
movie i'm not even in la anymore and
like every time i date somebody they
just like
drag my career down and i've worked too
hard to get to where i am i might move
to san francisco
this whole thing so she kept pushing and
kept pushing
and over that next year over 4th of july
it's like 110 degrees out and she's a
bar and restaurant designer she doesn't
come from
our world at all and so she
uh she came over to my house and helped
me build
a set for a youtube show i did called
the comlink
which was kind of like star wars show
before star wars show
and um and so she helped me do all of
that
in a hundred and ten degree heat on her
fourth of july vacation and i was kind
of like oh
wow well maybe i will give you the time
of day a lady
um and that is when you deign to [ __ ]
her
what a good soul you have um
and so that's kind of like when
everything took off but what she does
for me
now is she watches our baby all the time
handles everything at the house handles
everything with the kid
and runs her own design firm
at the same time so that i can come here
and and play nerd with you guys and and
do it at home at night
you know on the youtube so that's what
jen does for me is she does
she takes care of my whole world so that
i can do this
you got [ __ ] lucky give it up for jen
jc's gen i i love that jc's story begins
with
so i was this unattainable piece of ass
and i play really hard to get but maybe
you might get lucky
that story did take twists and turns um
all right what do we got next
okay uh uncle noah uncle noah where are
you man
come on come on
thank you thank you ark who goes there
it's noah
how are you sir i'm doing quite well
thank you excellent jacket man
thank you i like that collection facial
hair is strong and is that testy shirt i
see
absolutely oh my boy got her up
okay so batman has the penny the big
card and the t-rex yes so what three
items from your adventures
would you have in your cage we just
heard the best question of the night
that's phenomenal um okay
not to take anything away from the
previous questions but that is pretty
phenomenal
wow what three [ __ ] items are in my
bat cave
it's so weird because in real life i've
collected them all like i got the quick
stop sign from quick stop and [ __ ] like
that like i've i've been doing that
really if you want to see what my
batcave would look like just go to jay
and zombop secret stash
everything's up in [ __ ] trophy cases
already but if i went
personal oh okay
all right i'm going personal um i want
uh my first word processor
that was a smith corona electric
typewriter and then you
built a uh you bought a package that had
a monitor and this floppy disk drive
that attached to the electric typewriter
the electric typewriter became the
keyboard
and it saved information onto data
drives and then the
typewriter was the printer as well so it
printed out like you know
not even dot matrix as if it was typing
so it took a long [ __ ] time on that
uh word processor which was a gift from
my parents and like
you know i'm sure back when we they
bought it it was cost like 250 bucks but
that was
everything in the [ __ ] world and
stuff so and it was
predicated on a dream right like they
didn't know i could
[ __ ] write you know i i said i could
write and i'm like all right well here
you go this is what writers use and
stuff
and that changed my life i wrote clerks
on that i wrote like
mall rats the beginning of all rats on
that then i left
that personal word processor and got a
apple laptop that was
mobile and it was like that moment in
[ __ ]
you know almost famous where they leave
the bus behind and get on the plane and
[ __ ]
and then oddly enough mall rats almost
killed my career like that [ __ ] plane
did and [ __ ]
it's my favorite movie yes um all right
so that would be one my
my word process my pwp the personal word
processor
um another one would be
um
okay [ __ ] my god i feel like on my
therapist couch
my metal steed which is a corny ass name
i had for my moped in the 80s
uh i had one too you had a moped as well
yeah i don't do
they make them anymore uh vespas they
still do scooters
but not the ones we had mopeds were
these like one step up from a [ __ ]
bike
and you poured gas oil mixture and stuff
like that but like it got me
to from home to like atlantic highlands
uh where i was dating my girlfriend like
kim lochren for years and years and
stuff
so i spent a lot of time on the highways
on on that bike it would break down all
the time there's a lot of frustration
with it and [ __ ] like that but there was
freedom
that was my first real taste of freedom
i could just go places without asking my
parents for a [ __ ] ride and stuff
like that
also taught me how to take care of
things i didn't have pets growing up and
stuff but i had to take care of the
moped otherwise i couldn't [ __ ] go
anywhere
and for as much bitching as i did for as
many times as i'd taken into the shop
that'd be amazing to like have in a
trophy room like see that moped
i used to get so many hand jobs because
of it
uh and then the third one is also kind
of a bike and i don't know if i've
talked about it elsewhere i probably
didn't talk about it here but like years
and years ago i wanted a
like a huffy bmx bike when they first
came out they were all the rage
people had them and stuff and all the
cool kids in town had them i had a
regular bike ass bike that could have
just could have been driven by a boy
girl like
had nothing about it that said this is
[ __ ] tough no roll bar in the front
or anything like that
so i told my parents like i really want
to get a bike like john kovic and
[ __ ] mike bellicose like everybody in
my class i want to get like a huffy bike
like a bmx bike
and so uh my mom was like your dad is
gonna make you one
and i was like okay all right well dad
works at the post office and i've never
seen him ben steel uh
[Laughter]
i don't know how this is gonna work out
so my father for the course of a week in
the garage i wasn't allowed to go out
there
built me a bike and then
uh it was a big ceremony my mom's like
your dad's done with the bike and he's
gonna give you the bike and
my whole family gathered it was in the
driveway of the house on 21 jackson
street
dad opens the garage door and i see
my old bike with a bunch of [ __ ] put on
it
so you know some [ __ ] that like was easy
to do like the handlebars you picked
those up at two guys and whatnot and
they were
kind of look like bmx handlebars with
like just the grips
um there was no roll bar in the front
so my father took like this piece of
[ __ ] pvc piping
and then chicken wired it between the
handlebars
to create the the absolute worst [ __ ]
roll bar in bike history
but like if you squint and look down
you'd be like oh yeah that's what it's
supposed to be and [ __ ]
um he put like this wrapped pad like in
the middle
like you know bmx bike had that one pipe
in the middle and
put a nut pad there in case you came off
it i didn't have one
pipe the thing in the middle of the bike
was big and [ __ ] round so he had this
gigantic wrap going around it looked
like a [ __ ] air conditioning wrap or
something like that
and uh he put on new tires but like that
didn't [ __ ] help
uh the bike was still [ __ ] green
still had [ __ ] fenders
which like bmx bikes did not have and
it had a number plate on it very yellow
with a black number almost looked like
the batman insignia with the number one
on it
and i remember i was incredibly well
raised my mother raised very polite
kids so i wasn't like what the [ __ ] dad
like look at this terrible [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] this took you a week
what are you [ __ ] nuts so instead i
was like oh my god it's
great man thank you and i ate [ __ ] about
that bike from my friends for years
they're like hey kev
how's that homemade [ __ ] a bmx
it was made by my father don so they
would call it the bmx by d.o.n
and you know it was a real like [ __ ]
cross to bear in my childhood
i will give you every [ __ ] cent i
have in the world if i could have that
bike back right now
so i would i would take that bike
[Music]
over to you my friend all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna go backward through time
ooh i like it um so the first time
i was ever on set of an episode of tv
that i wrote
was for castle rock and so i flew up to
we were shooting in in orange
massachusetts doubling from maine
and i had already mustered off the show
by that point like my contract was done
and we had written everything we were
going to write
and then i get a call from the showroom
it's like hey do you want to go to set i
said well yeah [ __ ] i want to go to set
i'm not working now i'd happily go to
set like great
we uh we have the money in the budget
you just fly you up there
and according to the writers guild and
and the agreements that we've signed
with the studios they got to fly like
first [ __ ] class man
it's sweet and i'm not like a first
class dude usually
so just like hey this is all for me now
yeah there's only one step above that
winchester jet i know
not there yet so i fly up to orange
massachusetts and you know i'm on set
for
you know four days i couldn't be there
for the whole shoot because they didn't
have to fly down for new york comic-con
but when you go to set and as a writer
and i didn't know they did this but they
did this apparently at least on castle
rock but on most shows they do this
you've got the the director's chair that
you're going to sit in right
the whole time and it's usually like
just kind of
in video village where they have the
monitors to look at but it's like behind
and off to the left
of the director so in case you've got a
thing to mention to him you can kind of
just hop up it's like hey man now it's
not i never did that because i'm like do
they do your [ __ ] thing because the
director would be like shut the [ __ ] up
who the [ __ ] are you
who let you on my set um but what they
they didn't tell me until i got there
was that they printed up
uh seat backs for everybody who's on a
member of the crew and so i have a seat
back that says castle rock mark bernard
and so when i left the set they're like
take it with you like we don't [ __ ]
need it
if you're never coming back take it with
you so i have like that's the first
thing that i have which was the
here's your actual the the totem of your
new career
like i kind of now have with me nice
that's in the back cave that's in the
bat cave
um when i was like 13 or 14 somewhere
between like
13 and 16 i want to say i was a massive
d d player
um like i like me and my buddies were
always gathering my friend
john shotter um he was like hockey
player workout dude in his basement he
was the dm and he just
like he played sports and dnd yeah
big [ __ ] like he was a he was he
eventually went into the military now a
lawyer
but was all about dnd wow and so we
would always go in his basement
and you know somebody would put the
snacks on the weight bench and we would
all just [ __ ] start playing
and i had my own collection snacks on
the weight bench sounds like my bedroom
growing up
my parents like here's your weight bench
i'm like and this is where the snacks
will go
welcome to the buffet um and i had my
own little collection of the books like
five or six of them
um but i just kept reading them like
over and over and over again the same
way that if you're if you're a nerd you
want to deep
dive into the nerdum of course i also
had all of my official handbooks of the
marvel universe
and all of the who's who of dc comics
and just rereading for data to absorb
that [ __ ]
and then when i went college started and
like i was kind of
thinking about moving out or whatever i
gave all of my books to a friend
and i was like do me a favor just hold
on to these for me it's like i got a
girlfriend i'm not playing that much
anymore just
you know just keep an eye on him and
then i never saw the books
again the friend i would ever keep in
touch with but
the books just vanished into the air but
d for me
and i tell this to people all the time
like how do i get into tv writing i'm
like do you play dunces and dragons
i was like well why i was like well
because the thing is you're sitting on a
table with people
telling stories together you know it's
all about
cooperative storytelling it's all about
and not making everybody feel bad about
their dumb ass decisions unless all you
bring onto the quest is a 50 foot of
rope
and like [ __ ] you could have
brought a sword but no you just got the
rope like
it's it's supportive and it's you're all
doing a thing and you're learning how
to take somebody's ideas and and improve
them and then pass them off to somebody
else
and and learning how to work with people
and learning how to respect people
that's the first place that i learned
how to do that so to have those books
back
to be is the sort of right that's the
second marker that goes in the glass
case in the back case
that goes in the glass case third item
third item um when i was a kid i loved
to build
model cars did you really i did like
what kind of the kind that you needed
glue or the snap together the kind you
needed glue like i was the dude
very talented with the newspaper on the
tv tray
and like the [ __ ] glue and twisting
the plastic pieces
out of the molds that [ __ ] was too hard
i was good at the snap
together models but [ __ ] once it had
required glue i was like
i know i was all about that i would
never build the engines because i was
like i'm closing this [ __ ] hood i can
glue that
nobody needs to know that there's an
engine in cutting corners like detroit
let's leave the engine out this is a
gravity car you get on a hill this is
amazing
um but so i uh pinto and my favorite
show
at the time um was the dukes of hazard
really [ __ ] love the dukes of hazzard
really
really cause even as a child i was like
no
this this seems weird no
but no like i was like eight or nine
years old and the [ __ ] like
launching an orange car over chasms like
what what is not to love if you're a kid
about that show there are things not to
love about that show
but uh i don't know if you ever saw the
roof of the car but but so like and so
i'm building my like 78
charger like you know the paint is
perfect and i'm you know the hubcaps are
on it looks great and i'm [ __ ]
i'm sitting there like in the living
room my parents are like watching
whatever's on tv
and i'm just sitting there painstakingly
trying to make sure
with like a protractor and like rulers
and [ __ ]
to get using math to get the dixie flag
perfectly square on the on the roof of
this car
this is the opening scene of your biopic
you know
people are like this kid's gonna learn
and i'll i'll never forget it because
like my parents are both there like
my mother who at that point was she was
a young mother but
she was born in the 40s so this would
have been she'd be 30 years old right
um like grew up marched did all of that
[ __ ] in the civil rights era
is watching her eight-year-old
black son gluing an emblem of hate
onto his toy he came from my body
but she never said anything oh
she's like he loves this he'll learn
like there's time
for us to add this to his life but for
now he loves doing
this and he loves this show so i want
that car
beautiful absolutely beautiful
[Applause]
how how long after that did she
eventually be like mark sit down
uh or just where's my toy okay we got
roof of that car
mark it's probably we've got issues um
what a beautiful
beautiful question beautiful answers um
all right
okay last one is from ken k
can jump up man
it's a killer question that you got to
follow but we feel you could do it ken
you've got work to do this is ken's
birthday
give it up for kevin his birthday hey
well that's the birthday gift
right there chasing amy's shirt from the
hundreds collection man
pretty dope i mean you know we do in
this bar when it's somebody's birthday
we sing we sing count three kids one two
three
happy birthday to
you happy birthday
to you happy birthday
dear again
and harley happy
[Applause]
wait how old are you my kid's 22 33. so
my kid was born when you were 11. you
could have babysat my kid
where were you i could have used the
[ __ ] help kid was real [ __ ] needy
i never thought i would ever hear you
saying happy birthday to me like my
entire life so this is
this is a lot for me to take in thank
you right on
my question was what movie failed in the
theaters
that feel that you feel deserves a
remake that you would spearhead
what movie that failed in the theaters
deserves a remake that i would like to
spearhead
i know one ooh go masters of the
universe
i i i don't know why but i think i might
be able to handle that one now um they
remade this
i don't know 10 15 years ago it was okay
it wasn't great it has sean bean in it
and he's always cool but it was fine
the hitcher oh that's a [ __ ] dope
flick the original
tommy howell and rucker and yeah like
it's such a
lean idea it's such a simple idea you
know this [ __ ] dude is driving a
country a car across country he's not
his car
just doing a [ __ ] thing and some dude
like he i'll pick a
pick up a hitchhiker i'm gonna
experience the road for all it has
and he picks up rucker howard who
decides then to spend the rest of the
movie
terrorizing see thomas howell yeah you
know killing people
yeah and this was early like in the days
before this was a trope in films
like i remember seeing this movie be
like this is new yeah but it's one of
those
it's a movie that gives him no reason
for why he does what he does
and the the scariness of it is this
could happen to anybody at any time
just because if you have a car if you
have a car so ride a moped that's what i
learned from that movie
but it's the it's the the breakdown of
the social contract right there's
another movie that would come out later
um called funny games by a director
named michael hanecki
one of the most terrifying films i've
ever seen in my life if you've not
seen funny games there's two versions
yeah which he directed them both he did
both it's [ __ ] insane there's a
german version
right they speak where it's all in
german and that's [ __ ] terrifying but
then they did an english-speaking
version
yeah which is [ __ ] equally as
terrifying and the only movie that my
wife was like i
was angrily and so angry at me for like
saying let's watch this
she was like that was [ __ ] repugnant
to me she was like that was [ __ ]
terrifying i can't do that ever again
why did you make me do that and [ __ ]
see that or our sex i forget which
conversation that was after
but yeah she was really scared by the
movie and it is like you want to talk
about [ __ ]
hopeless the social contract breaks down
yeah it's literally just
people in their house living their lives
and then a couple of home intruders come
and terrorize relentless they won't be
stopped
and for no reason yeah just we wanted to
do it today
and so that's what the hitcher feels
like and so i feel like
we we keep burging into these zones
these eras
of a little bit of xenophobia a little
bit of distrust
among people a little bit of i'm not
sure if there are roads that i should be
driving down the the myth of america
and the road trip and the freedom of the
highways and how you can find ways to
to diminish that freedom and twist it
and pervert it into something scary
like that movie it frightened the [ __ ]
out of me when i first saw it on hbo
like it probably was an hbo movie if i
remember correctly
hbo made it but and then it went to hbo
but like when
it was like the dv the vid video to the
vhs it was like hbo
thorne emma something like that um but i
think that idea there's still something
really powerful in that idea
um so yeah that's that's what i would do
sometimes like what do you want to do
next
the hitcher [ __ ] love it man there it
is there's your answers you're content
that's your birthday present happy
birthday
[Applause]
all right my back of choice would be
yoga hosers thank you very much
um all right so we heard three questions
or we done so with a question we had
three questions
plus the youtube plus the youtube
question all right this is
a question we gave away they got a prize
um
hands down i think this is the prize of
the [ __ ] night because i know how
much this [ __ ] goes for
and this absolutely goes to the great
question that i already forgot what was
the great question oh [ __ ] the bat
cave
oh you come on up
[Applause]
and also you get amazing yeah hold on
there's more
and you get a poster as well but wait
there's more
look in that camera and be like holy
[ __ ] look what i won
[Applause]
that was his audition it was great this
is why they won't let me host a game
show i'm like look at the camera and
curse they're like you know
uh this ladies and gentlemen i remember
the other day we had a batman maquette
that was damaged
this is a wonder woman maquette that was
damaged she's been missing a hand for 10
years
um it is a limited edition 2500
uh of these uh gorgeous bruce tim drawn
uh wonder womans that they used to sell
at the warner brothers store back when
it existed 250
artist proofs and somehow this is number
290
regardless one of a kind man
did you do that thing oh that one i
haven't done yet that requires all the
writing and stuff
and so we also have a autographed copy
of smartest in residence
as drawn by the great dark nate himself
gorgeous book full of all the artwork he
ever created for this show
and some more manscape [ __ ] that's true
hold on kevin and mark can you do
toy power don't mind us
yes sorry talk amongst yourselves to the
toy
power podcast
i heart you so long and thanks for all
the fish and then you get in there
you get in there man two toy power
podcast they don't want me to write it
twice i think you could probably just
i can skip your name boom okay
well done um okay so that means we have
two prizes to give out we gave out the
hoodie
um wonder woman statue so we only have
one prize
how many questions we have two two left
to give all right so one question was
what's the what our wives do yes which
is a great question
so that's actually the second best
question of the night you win come on up
pick your prize up my friend
[Applause]
broken wonder woman or manscaped dark
nate
the handless wonder woman she's taking
the hand job you want us to
to hand i can tell you exactly what
happened in the hand louie our third dog
bit it off the [ __ ] jerk
but she's dead now so i feel bad about
that oh hell yes
how about we tag the legs is that cool
done and done
and then you do it as well had she
selected the manscape
it says more about the guy she's sitting
next to then
that's true she's making a low-key
statement about how bushy you are
look into that camera and be like i'm
going to shave my man's balls
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's the stuff
i i'm not an effective director mark
say this you need anyone to do my lines
uh that means that our last question uh
is our birthday boy correct
correct so that means our birthday boy
is going to win the smartest book
the print and another box and another
box of landscape stuff come on
up man
[Applause]
the good folks at manscaped look at all
oh my god it comes with a sweet [ __ ]
bag a ball bag if you will
this is going to be for you man that's
true a ball sack
and look at all that look at the
fabulous prizes it comes you're going to
have the nicest smell of nuts in town
look at that camera and be like smell my
fresh nuts
yes give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
how you feeling banff man i feel good i
feel like with all the uh
man grooming out here we could use some
blue chew
yeah you're not kidding that'd be
helpful perhaps it'll look so much
bigger once all that hair is good that's
true
blue chew manscape together will make
your dick huge the dynamic duo
we thank the good folks at blue chew for
sponsoring uh this episode
of fat man beyond this very fun episode
of fat man beyond i had a great [ __ ]
time
about you man that was a fantastic
saturday afternoon
way to do it right on a saturday
afternoon and we got one hat here man
from
holy cow burgers in austin texas bam
good folks they provided us with uh
hamburgers for the movies pop-up when we
were in austin movies pop-up is
happening right now in oklahoma city i
believe
uh coming to detroit next week and also
toronto
go to moviespopup.com if you're into
that sort of thing these movies are they
just keep going man
it's been really [ __ ] special side
hustle uh it is a nice side hustle
uh if uh if you're on the east coast and
you're like [ __ ] i wish i could be
in the bar with those cats and [ __ ] like
that uh well you'll you can
get half of what you want because i'm
heading back uh to jersey uh july six
i'm gonna be there all summer
in jersey we open smod castle our
performance space on july 9th 10th and
11th you can get tickets right now for
the weekend of shows
uh at seasmod.com what do you want to
sell
i just want to sell joy you guys i just
i just i just want to sell the
the warmth in my heart for everybody i
want to sell
i want to sell giant throbbing hard
dicks
by code bluechew.com
man i just want to sell
i don't know t-shirts there you go hey
yeah
where can they get your uh yeah i've
seen a couple of uh be humble but let
[ __ ] know
yes in the crowd so go to
embattledclothing.com
um and pick one out for yourself
absolutely kids
ladies and gentlemen of scum and
villainy cantina right here in hollywood
on hollywood boulevard man did you have
a good time this afternoon
we can't thank you enough for coming out
this is the last time we do it for a lo
for a red house until the wall yeah
we'll we'll be doing hybrid shows though
mark will do we're going to try out the
show where mark's here and omits mod
castle and stuff like that so
that could be a wonderful train wreck
please come to that show
uh mark of course is gonna be here solo
doing his uh
snyder cut commentary sooner or later i
will as part of black man beyond
i mean i'm sure if people encourage him
online i know he works all the time and
stuff but if everybody kind of
needles them i bet you you could
convince them to come do some regular
black man beyonds here if you're
i think i think i think i can yeah
you know and and there might be a world
in which i i take a quick hop back east
and uh and then we could do that's right
we'll be doing in the spot castle
together man that's right your lady will
want to go home
she will i'm sure i'm going to bring her
though her home her neck of the woods
yeah are you guys going to tell me are
you going to supernatural me out of that
show
[Applause]
we'll send the chat jc's gonna put up
his tweet where he's just like i'm happy
for you guys
but i wish somebody would have mentioned
it to me
uh we don't have a [ __ ] show ladies
and gentlemen without the guy standing
over there give it up for banff man
himself j.c
reiffenberg
scum and villainy cantina is open for
business come down here
get your drink on nobody ever fights
here man and
if they do somebody gets an arm cut off
and it's all [ __ ] good
uh if you enjoy uh the antics of fat man
beyond ladies and gentlemen
uh that means that you're very thankful
to the man to my left without whom there
is no fat man beyond give it up for mr
mark bernard
and that is fat man beyond for this week
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernardin tune
in next time same fat time same fat
channel smartcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith happy birthday
harley quinn
happy birthday
[Music]